facebook and all of its apps and
third-party
apps went down
we don't know exactly why i mean people
are saying it has to do with dns all of
a sudden facebook wasn't registering
people were posting images where you
could apparently go to domain registry
websites and type in facebook.com and
they would say you can buy this for
fifteen dollars so something went down
and they're saying amazing to do with
something called the you know bgp pro
you know something like that it's a you
know border something protocol we'll
read all about this however
a lot of people think something else
happened because this was a total
shutdown of facebook whatsapp instagram
messenger as well as log in with
facebook on all third-party apps and it
was it was happening for like six hours
or longer at the same time we're getting
another story that a massive hack hit
facebook leaving 1.5 was a 1.5 billion
people's information now available for
download we don't know that they're
related but you do have these two big
stories leading people to question
what's going on with facebook and the
funny thing is when this news was
happening i'm like my instagram's not
loading everyone i mentioned mentioned
this to said the exact same thing well i
hope it doesn't come back yeah everybody
hates facebook but we got a bunch of
other news too
we got new york city largest healthcare
provider shut uh fired like a thousand
nurses and the more important news
let me ask you a question how many
citations violations do you think new
york city has handed out since the start
of their vaccine mandate just just think
of a number they got what 2.5 million
people in manhattan alone you've got
like 9 million in the metro come on new
york city how many they've given out
ten
ten you that means they have no ability
to enforce this the only reason there's
vaccine mandates in new york city is
because regular people are willing to
drop to their knees the moment their
their their monarch tells them to
they're sovereign and if regular people
just said i don't agree with them won't
do it it wouldn't happen
but we have bigger news than that my
friends first of all ariel scarcel is
joining us
um hi
um you had me on your podcast last last
year i think we were we were hanging out
and yeah you were one of the people that
helped red pill me or purple peel me
whatever we want to call it these days
purple pills wake up eminem um
well you were uh i guess you were
worried about losing friends and yeah i
was i was very worried about i lost
about 50 friends friends
and yeah they weren't no they weren't
you and sydney watson were the people
that were like standing by my side and i
was like you know what this is the place
to be right now because even if i don't
agree with them on things they're not
going to unfriend me or unfollow me or
try to eff my business up yeah because
what my beliefs yeah i definitely want
to talk about that especially
considering what's going on with like
the massive divide getting worse but the
the big breaking story ladies and
gentlemen the biggest news luke
gronkowski has returned facebook and
instagram have been down for six six
hours and 15 minutes and the mental
spiritual well-being of tweens and
teenagers has never been better welcome
back beautiful and amazing human beings
this is lukadowski here of we are
change.org it's good to be back i'm back
here mainly for country and for duty as
of course we are in a very serious time
right now and i think we need everyone
to step it up we need everyone to be on
the front lines we need everyone to work
overtime and i'm here reporting for duty
because i think we are literally at a
precipice we are at a watershed moment
where we could go in two different paths
we could go down a big brother orwellian
establishment or overlord
slave world or we could go to one where
we still have the ideas of liberty
personal choice and freedom and i'm here
making sure we go on the right path good
to be back and uh thanks for having me
thanks ian i got to say for real for the
first time i can say this and mean it
rudkowski in the housekeeper
welcome back sir great to have you here
and ariel you were like one of the first
guests on irl when they started doing
yes before i was on the show i'm so glad
to finally be on the show with you yeah
hello great to see you again
oh yeah didn't we didn't we like make a
funny video like we titled it something
funny i don't remember i just remember i
was one of the first guests yeah yeah
leftist youtuber red build something
like that yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
that's the truth i think for jack murphy
we said like rage quits yeah democratic
party i did yes i said that yeah that's
good and we got lydia pressing the
buttons yeah i'm in the corner pushing
buttons happy to be with my pals ariel
and luke again it's gonna be a great
night i can tell already and we have
such huge news i'm excited so we were
expecting the new studio to be done
and so i'm like i'm gonna i'm gonna wear
a new i'm gonna wear new clothes people
listening and listening don't realize
i'm wearing something different he is
and i'm wearing black sleeves and a
black beanie which like
i'm fading phasing into the background
but uh the new show the walls are all
like it's going to be more uniform how
everyone's like we we we fully built out
this thing it was a long long project a
couple months and uh we had to steam
clean you know good to get the cat smell
out that was kind of an issue you know
ian was like this cat monger and he had
just like cats
no buckling my head off well i think the
previous owners had animals too so we
had to really go in there so we had to
steam clean it we did like a hot thing
they had a wand and they were like
really getting and then they polished
the walls so now they're now the studio
is being built so maybe tomorrow yeah
we'll see but before we get started my
friends we have an amazing sponsor we
have
biotrust just go to
eatrightfeelwell.com
eatrightandfeelwell.com that's it right
that's it yeah and you can get your keto
elevate mct oil powder 51 off now what
is this you ask this is the best kind of
medium chain triglyceride fats you put
in your coffee it's like almost like
creamer and it gives you that good keto
energy so if you're trying to eat right
cut out those sugars this stuff is
absolutely fantastic i've been doing
keto for the past couple of months i
gotta tell you all of a sudden i just
feel infinitely better and maybe it's
not keto maybe it's just cutting out
processed sugars we got a big old bowl
of fruit snacks right there i don't
touch them i don't need any garbage
anymore i've been putting this stuff in
my coffee every morning i feel like a
million bucks go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com and you can get
a 60-day money-back guarantee they say
keto elevate provides your body only c8
the most ketogenic mct in its purest
forms that means it provides very fast
and effective support for enhanced
energy levels healthy appetite
management enhancement clarity and focus
athletic performance
they say keto elevate is the most
advanced mct powder on the market today
and you get free shipping on every order
for every order today biotrust donates a
nutritious meal to a hungry child in
your honor through their partnership
with no kid hungry.org to date biotrust
has provided over 5 million meals to
hungry kids please help biotrust hit
their goal of 6 million meal meals this
year plus you will get free vip live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and that's the one that always blows me
away that's too good of a deal i don't
understand how they do that but that's
fantastic plus you'll get their new
e-report the top 14 ketogenic foods with
every order so go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com pick it up 51
off biotrust you guys rock you guys know
they're a big sponsor of our show we
have like three now different products
from them everyone house loves all of
their products and we never have enough
because we've got like 30 people working
here but you know special thank you
don't forget to go to timcast.com become
a member because we have a new show
you can't actually see it but over here
on the left there's a button tales from
the inverted world it just went live and
we have one episode up is the truth out
there this is the mystery paranormal
podcast show fully produced with sound
effects it is spooky stories true crime
murders ghosts bigfoot and as a member
you will not only get access to tim cast
irl members videos but we're actually
going to be producing members content
from tales from the inverted world which
is going to be hanging out with the
investigative reporter shane cashman as
well as other crazy characters like ian
for instance talking about conspiracy
theories yeah and you'll get an ad free
experience supporting all the work we do
so now that we've said now that i've
said all of those things let's actually
talk about some news
we got this big story from wired.com
wired says why facebook why why facebook
instagram and whatsapp all went down
today the problem relates to something
called bgp routing and it took down
every part of facebook's business so
they say around 11 40 a.m eastern time
the domain name system records became
unreachable
uh facebook's outage appears to be
caused by dns however that's just a
symptom of the problem says troy mersch
chief research officer of cyber threat
intelligence company bad packets the
fundamental issue issue he says and
other experts agree is that facebook has
withdrawn the so-called border gateway
protocol route that contains the ip
addresses of its dns name servers if dns
is the internet's phone book bgp is its
navigation system it decides what route
data takes as it travels the information
superhighway
you can think of it like a game of
telephone
but instead of people playing it's
smaller networks letting each other know
how to reach them says angelique medina
director of product marketing at the
network monitoring firm cisco thousand
dies they announce this route to their
neighbor and their neighbor will
propagate it out to their peers it's a
lot of jargon they say facebook has
fallen off the internet's map if you try
to ping those ips the packets end up in
a black hole so why did this happen well
let me show you one other story real
quick because this is where i think the
story actually becomes bigger on the
same day at 4 27 p.m newsweek reports
1.5 billion facebook users personal
information posted for sale after hack
could these be related i don't know
it seems like the dns thing might have
been an inside job
well whatever the official story is i
don't believe it and i don't think we
should
because where we're getting all the
information from i mean we got the new
york times reporting that this was
unlikely a hack we have rt saying that
on hacker forums there were discussions
about this but we're still waiting for a
lot of this to still settle because it's
still just broke it was six hours 15
minutes and
we're getting reports from bloomberg
that mark zuckerberg lost seven billion
dollars and actually went down on the
list of world's richest people
significantly because of this all of
course as there's a major facebook
whistleblower and major mainstream media
stories attacking them for not censoring
enough information i think
even though i don't have any evidence
for this i think that there might be
something else up here that's bigger
that could be a sign or a signal against
facebook to step in line that's my just
personal opinion and i don't have any
evidence to is it is it kind of sad that
mark zuckerberg losing seven billion
dollars doesn't matter to him probably
why would it well it is kind of like a
slippery slope kind of thing though
because if this happens for seven days
straight
people are gone facebook's over that
would be awesome
yeah that would be really good
i mean
last year when i was on the show i kept
talking about the destruction of mental
health especially with big tech social
media and even though this facebook
whistleblower is calling for uh big
government to intervene she does
highlight a big problem and that's the
mental health crisis that is created by
big tech social media that knowingly is
hurting people knowingly is creating
algorithms that promote self-harm
suicide depression we look at our mental
health as a country it has gone down
dramatically and it will continue to go
down and it started to go down
dramatically during the the major usage
of social media so there's something to
really talk about here we need a
discussion and and i think the
discussion should be led by is our life
better without big tech social media
yes and that's coming from people that
do this for a living so we we genuinely
care about this
youtube's a little bit different from
facebook but still a lot of the similar
similar problems and so what they've
done is they've tried eliminating what
they view as fringe and therein lies the
problem
the the internet space got so big and so
wide so quickly that there was this huge
different like world of content and
opinions and personalities and then all
of a sudden the people that facebook
twitter youtube were like hey we gotta
we gotta reign this in because this is
getting crazy and then they decided
we're centrists we're good rational
people marx was right now let's ban
anybody who disagrees and that's when
they started going after like moderates
conservatives people who tweeted learn
to code yeah pretty much i had four
pages taken down by facebook and they
weren't even that controversial it was
just about asking questions and and a
lot of people probably that we know
about had their facebook page taken down
i think you had yours affected as well
uh but we have to understand that you
know facebook is is a major company and
they have knowingly done psychological
experiments trying to manipulate
people's emotions through manipulating
their news feed so they've been doing
this years ago and i've been called a
conspiracy theorist like you're crazy
you're insane if you think that they can
make you depressed with your news i'm
like they were literally doing the test
with major universities out in the open
publicly bragging about it so to tell me
that they're standing uh idly by as we
have this record amount of self-harm and
again you could go on and and go on
different tangents i really want to talk
about how self-harm and depression leads
to more corporatism and more people
filling the empty void by buying useless
corporate crap and how this could be a
kind of bigger conspiracy here but i
don't want to go off on too much
attendance but i i think we all know
someone that has been very negatively
affected by social media either by being
censored or just being affected by what
is being uh thrown at them i just want
to pull up this fact check real quick
because you guys luke is completely
correct in the atlantic reports
everything we know about facebook's
secret mood manipulation experiment they
say
for one week in 2012 data scientists
skewed what almost 700 000 facebook
users saw when they logged in with
service some people were shown content
with a preponderance of happy and
positive words some were shown content
analyzed as sadder than average and when
the week was over these manipulated
users were more likely to post either
especially positive or negative words
themselves
facebook knows they're manipulating
people they know how to do it
but they were experimenting on people
without them even knowing that they were
being experimented on so this is the
level of data so let's just say there is
a hack if there is a hack all of your
private information facebook and big
tech knows when you literally take a
dump they literally know the the second
that you have the most intimate moments
in your existence and they exploit that
for corporate benefit there's people who
don't know that they're pregnant that
are literally getting pregnancy ads
because facebook knows that they're
pregnant before they are so this is the
level of information that they have on
you the data sets that they have on you
so let's just say hypothetically we
don't we haven't have confirmations we
have some reporting that there might be
some hacker leaks if if everyone's
private information about when they take
a dump when they have it comes out i
mean that's like some serious
information i wouldn't want people yes
yes yes
but but hold on a minute i want you to
imagine the utopia of this future right
imagine so i'm wearing the smart watch
okay
and uh you know i'm looking at it and
what if all of a sudden it just chimed
and a little voice popped up and said
hello timothy it's time to poop and i
was like hey wait a minute it is i did
not know that
and then facebook was able to tell me
when i should go to the bathroom or like
facebook can track your cycle for you oh
everything we don't you dude didn't they
have that you don't even think
they had an experiment years ago where
people were in a
you know the whole holding space
whatever it was and they told them that
they had to wait a certain number of
time for the experiment but the
experiment was actually the fact that
they were waiting
and do you remember that is it there's a
bunch like that yeah and it the clock
actually moved like two times faster
than it normally would
or something and do you remember this
and at one o'clock everyone it was
really like 11 but people were hungry
because they thought it was one o'clock
wow yeah yeah no it's a real thing i
mean brain manipulation the brain is is
so ridiculous ridiculously so so
powerful so hold on you know luke you're
mentioning that instagram and face
facebook make young women go insane
right you know about the stuff right um
i could tell you from a cultural
perspective from the dating field what's
going on in the dating world yeah just
culturally like my target audience is
young women right like young women and
lgbt people that are saying thank god
but the majority of people that have
mental health problems are young women
in general so i think social media is is
going to affect them more than anybody
else when you break down social media
too you got to kind of define it because
there's video chat where two people are
talking and it's being recorded that's
kind of cool then you have videos
where's one person talking that's a
little more psychotic then you have text
which is incredibly to think that you're
communicating with someone by reading
etchings on a wall that they put there
is to me is insanity
exactly so so here's an example i
tweeted i tweeted today people who claim
to oppose vaccine mandates but then get
vaccinated because they're scared of
losing their job and money aren't
actually opposing the mandates and
there's two ways you can interpret this
one is i'm saying they don't have
negative feelings towards the mandates
or the other is they are not actively
blocking it right so my point was if i
said i'm going to stop this bottle of
water from hitting the floor and then i
threw it on the floor i'm doing the
opposite of what i said i was going to
do i'm not actually trying to stop it
from hitting the floor but because it's
text this very short tweet the context
wasn't there and so half the people
think i'm i'm saying quite literally
that they don't actually dislike the
mandates right i posted um i retweeted
boyan slats ocean cleanup project
they're pulling trash out of the pacific
garbage patch and it was basically he
was like we're one sixty thousandth of
the way there we've almost got all the
trash kind of wink wink but for real one
sixty thousand the way they're seven
years off and someone just other people
were seeing it and the context to them
was we're doomed look at all that trash
we're doomed
boiling slot is actually a bilderberg
member i confronted him at and did an
interview with him uh on my channel very
fascinating young man uh but but just to
get to the larger topic here you know
our perceptions are shaped by
literal tech overlords that decide how
we feel and when you control how someone
could feel when you when you control
what information they see and what they
did was really dastardly because they
took raw independent information they
took journalists that were actually
doing good work censored them first then
they went after all the little troubled
some people and the troubled some
political personalities but they went
after political people first that were a
part of the culture uh so we have to
make that clear over people who hurt
children uh we can't even say that word
here uh there was a large number of
people abusing that platform in very
specific horrible ways but they went
after culture and when we look at people
who are consuming the news feed
especially the violent content that they
see whether it's police officers beating
someone up or blm beating someone up or
antifa beating someone up that has such
a larger psychological effect that we
really truly need to discuss this
because the ramifications are affected
are felt here and when you have sinister
multinational corporations especially
facebook with their connections with
intelligence agencies at the helm plug
in buttons saying we could control and
manipulate society this way or this way
and make them feel this way this way
that's god-like power and god-like
authority that needs to be put in
checked immediately i'm just sitting
here as like luke's doing this like huge
anti-facebook rant and ian's eyes are
getting wider
what's happening
but but look look one of the important
things it's like we'll pull it back a
little bit is that young women on
instagram are being fed this fake
reality with filters with just photoshop
and then they're trying they're like
it's like an escalation every day of
trying to look more and more like some
kind of cartoon character and because
they can't they're getting depressed
was a story i read about this young girl
who's like
she posted a photo on instagram
and then looked at her watch and tracked
how many likes she got in the first
minute and when she was down she deleted
it right away like oh no that was bad
what did i do oh geez i'm not getting
enough likes
that facebook knows they're driving this
into people's minds and making them go
insane have you so you said you're the
ariel that the majority of your audience
is young women have you noticed do you
in communication with them like a change
in their
personalities over the last several
years
oh yeah oh yeah 100 i used to i used to
make videos for young women and they
used to love my channel and now because
i'm not
um claiming that i'm oppressed and
depressed and all these things you know
and i'm not one with them anymore i'm
you know then they wound up starting to
hate me it was it was a shame and i've
seen more people become more mentally
ill in my opinion than ever before
well the algorithm doesn't feed into
that but also people don't relate to
that because of the kind of images that
they have but there's a lot of articles
that i just kind of pulled up here one
of them is titled toxic filters that
warp reality and make young girls hate
their bodies there's another article 90
of women report using a filter on their
photos so so there's a lot of things
underlyingly happening here um that that
dude deserve a bigger coverage these are
like two different things really it's
like
you have that at the same time you know
you have young women trying to photoshop
themselves at the same time you have the
weird gen z
i don't know if it's gen z or whatever
woke crowd on youtube so i i'm curious
though you mentioned that your audience
used to be like
have you lost audience
when oh so let's slow down you were like
uh you know an lgbt youtube channel or
whatever and then you just didn't agree
with a lot of the weird woke stuff
did you see a loss in viewership how did
this change happen where all of a sudden
people who are like slowly becoming woke
and like how did you realize it oh my
god i've realized it since i would say
2015. that's when it really really
started hitting
hitting the i would say the back end of
the lgbt community
um it started becoming public
for like the heteros out there um
outside like around 2018 when when
unfortunately when like the trans or the
trans community um started coming around
and you if you really look into the
trans community
it's mostly young
people that are born female yeah that
are young
exactly and it's in it's mostly in my
opinion women young women that are
either depressed or they have mental
health issues or they have eating
disorders and they hate their bodies or
they feel like they
because they believe that they're
oppressed and they don't want to be a
woman so they identify as everything
else in between or whatever and it's
it's a it's a real shame because i've
always been a promoter and believer of
of strong women like i want to make
women stronger because i believe that we
are strong what what's their objection
to you all of a sudden because i wasn't
i wasn't going along with what they
believed anymore i was i'm like no we we
have to continuously push we have to
push our push our boundaries we have to
push ourselves
and they just they didn't want to hear
it anymore and they and because i wasn't
going along with it they felt like i
turned on them and i said no i'm
promoting the same things i've always
promoted
actual body positivity
actual empowerment
none of this woke bs stuff
we had we had someone super chat us a
couple weeks ago saying like you guys
are radicalized and like he's like i'm a
leftist and you guys are radicalized and
it's like
how is it radical to be status quo you
know what i mean like and i'm not saying
status quo is a good thing like it's
it's kind of a self-deprecation here
like we are
rather like regular liberal
you know
typical most most americans are like we
like we are at the moment i'll put it
this way i think you and i probably have
very similar politics like center left
leaning you know urban
liberal luke's more libertarian i don't
know what i am i i believe in freedom
and not believing the government
and personal responsibility i would say
technically that's probably like
libertarian right now i think it's a
political compass i'm like don't label
me economically left-leaning libertarian
i'm like in the middle of that bottom
left square oh there according to the
one test and i asked my people on
twitter my people what's up to uh take
the test let me know every one of them
was a libertarian no authoritarians so
it makes me think this whole left right
thing's kind of bold but it's more about
are you an authoritarian or are you not
are you upwind or downward
downwing is goodwing no i i agree with
that i think they started they started
wanting to control how i thought who i
was hanging out with what i was allowed
to say and i was like absolutely effing
not like i'm not doing that and i
started going against the grain but i've
always gone against the grain nothing
new here isn't it just said they started
going
like what would they say there was that
meme like the old left don't tell me
what to do and the new left listen to
what they tell you well that's it that's
like that's really what happens rage
against the machine yeah
you i won't do what you tell me and now
it's fu you better do what we tell you
and what about green day
don't want to be an american idiot
remember that song yeah that was right
afterwards controlled by the media yeah
it's like they knew this back then these
people and people are still falling for
it it's funny because like there was a
point where
i guess you know you're doing lgbt
content it's controversial you know
going back now it's dominant mainstream
and if you don't adhere to it and i
don't mean just lgbt stuff i mean like
social justice in general is no longer
counterculture it is establishment
fallen line or else
right and i wouldn't have that i'm not
doing it
like back then
you know
conservatives at that point 2011 when i
first started making content on youtube
in 2009 i'm like the og lesbian
conservatives back then like a lot of
conservatives
weren't really pro necessarily pro gay
marriage right or pro gay rights i think
they still mostly oppose it well not
like well we're like new age
conservatives like more or less like
these types of people i don't think
you're a conservative no i'm a
libertarian i think probably yeah like
yeah yeah but like i lean conservative
on certain issues so i say yeah whatever
but like
back then
you know i felt like i had to side with
democrats because those at the time were
the only people that were promoting gay
rights and gay marriage and that makes
sense and now it's like okay we have
those rights
they don't own me anymore like there are
other people that are fighting for us
that i might agree with more like trump
i agree with a lot of his policies
my voice is getting high
but i but i agree with something i'm
saying i don't know i mean look how look
have you seen all the chance of f joe
biden sweeping across the country yes
and somebody was like something go
brandon yeah
it was like the media summed up in eight
seconds or something somebody tried it i
don't believe these polls
at all the polls were like the polls
were so dramatically wrong in 2020 so
the presidential election stuff a lot of
people i don't think we're able to
predict accurately some people were but
the congress was really a shock it was a
red wave it wasn't as big as republicans
needed but like miami miami going
republican wow can't say i'm surprised
that doesn't surprise me people fleeing
cuba yeah you know uh and family and
friends and then southern texas so a lot
of that surprised a lot of people but
now we see these polls where they're
like democrats you know what i'll tell
you this i look at these aggregate polls
and they say
joe biden independence hate him it's
like his disapproval among independents
like 65
independents are where regular americans
are because democrats overwhelmingly
just like democrats republicans
overwhelmingly don't like democrats
republicans actually don't like the
republican party it's kind of hilarious
and then independent voters are like i
don't know but all of a sudden you're
getting people at football games
screaming f joe biden
it's not like nascar i kind of get okay
yeah the nascar people are screaming
football games that's a big deal because
it's college it's college it's not just
college but it's a lot of them too yeah
but a lot of but if you i travel a lot
every single college town is liberal
every single one oh yeah of course yes
so that's very surprising to me cities
in general
yes yes so weird biden's a bad leader
terrible terrible terrible that that is
that is unfair ian
bad it does not encompass how horrible
true i wasn't effective enough
his surrender in afghanistan is just
obliteratively uh in in
indescriba indestructible i don't know
what the right word is but it's just
indescribable incomprehensible it's
dangerous yeah if someone posted that if
we get it if eric weinstein i think said
that it looks like now if there actually
was an attack on us that that's so
disorganized and people have such little
faith in leadership that we wouldn't be
able to mobilize an army well i think
there's definitely concerted efforts to
destroy america because america still
stands for the ideas of personal liberty
freedoms uh the first amendment the
second amendment you don't see that
anywhere else in the world and for a lot
of multinational corporations to kind of
fully roll a lot of you know powerful
people that want to have total control
like they have in china they need to
destroy this idea and that that's why i
think culturally there's there has been
such a push especially with the young
children not to be patriotic not to
stand up for the country there's also
something to say about not being too
nationalistic i mean i understand both
arguments here but kind of segwaying
back to what we were just talking about
i do believe that the destruction of
people's confidence and happiness has
been deliberate i do believe it could
even be a part of fourth generational
warfare something that of course former
kgb agent yuri besnoff weren't warned
about i think all those warnings that
that yuri besnoff when he was
interviewed by g edward griffin if you
haven't saw that video yet i definitely
recommend you do because he nails it to
the t exactly what's happening right now
the destruction of happiness the
destruction of culture the destruction
from within a moral loss that is
happening within this country and i and
i think it's done deliberately because
when you take down america you take down
its ideas you take down any kind of
resistance towards full censorship full
control full enslavement of humanity
let's wrap these ideas together
ariel you make you know lgbt videos
something that around the world is
extremely controversial and a lot of
countries literally execute people for
this stuff it's horrifying yes in
america there's a country that gives you
the freedom of speech and the the
neutrality of law enforcement not
perfectly mind you but in many respects
no one's allowed to go to your house and
break break it down and attack you and
beat you and don't cause any harm
because you're expressing those opinions
as much as a lot of people don't like
them and then through efforts of
activists like you in america you've
proven america works that's
you you've had tremendous victories you
mentioned just earlier it's like hey we
you know we we got a lot of that we
wanted i don't i'm not owned by you
anymore but see you know what it is
they thought they were going to use that
that that that characteristic about you
to then say let's destroy america it's
like what do you mean like the country
is did really well in granting expansive
civil rights to different various groups
why would i be upset with the country
i'm happy with the country yeah they
want you to tear it down oh yeah
look what happened with with um
with you know the whole israel versus
the middle east it's like
most of these you know social justice
you know leftists
are fighting
for
you know they're more on the other side
of palestine yeah and it's bizarre like
i've never and they in the middle east
countries it's the worst place to be as
a gay person
it's bizarre
i don't understand why israel's a
secular democracy yeah in in in a
theater in a theistic fascistic region
and a lot of things to criticize them
for but it really is funny when you see
like you know ilhan omar
say like we we must sanction israel and
then then all of a sudden they're like
hey we're going to sanction turkey no no
no no not turkey yeah because it's not
about
principle no it's not about easily
quantifiable this is right or this is
wrong it's about i want power and i want
my side to win and i'll use whatever it
takes whatever i can do together chess
pieces yeah 100 and it's obvious it's
like i think more lgbt people are waking
up more than ever before i think i've
read pills
whatever you would call it whatever you
want to call it i don't read as in
conservative but red pill doesn't like
wake up for real like this is what's
actually happening i think people like
me and rob smith and my friend david
broke back patriot like we
are out blair white you know we're
outspoken lgbt people and i think
if it wasn't for people like us just
like in the beginning with me like when
i first started making videos we did not
have gay marriage in this country isn't
that crazy to think about wow i started
making videos in 2009 we didn't have gay
marriage until 2012 in new york
so i
i was in in some ways on the forefront
you know of of some gay rights nice you
know and i have people that i've worked
with this guy
um
that lives in vermont who was actually
in the stonewall riots like that's true
activism not what's happening now this
this unpatriotic movement and hating
america and it's like you
yeah go ahead go go and be gay in
another country see what happens what
are the stonewall riots
the stonewall riots um
technically the first riot believe it or
not was actually in philadelphia
interesting fact um but the first
official like parade
was in new york city in 1969 june i
believe june 28 1969 and it was the the
fight against the police because the
police were
messing with the gays in the in the
village mainly and they had a parade for
gay rights and that's that's kind of
when the movement started yeah it turned
to arrive it turned into a riot it was
originally like a
like a not a parade but a um a march i
guess
and then it became a riot yeah isn't it
the weirdest thing that you know when
you talk about freedom freedom itself
has become right-wing
yes which is bizarre so thank you yeah
it's that authoritarian verse
libertarian thing on the scale it's very
weird that there's like authoritarian
thorn in the side but it's but it's a
dog wants a cult it's not just
authoritarianism
it's it's the cult because even
you know even someone who's on the left
literally like jimmy dore man this guy
comes out ragging on the establishment
he's like we need universal health care
and you know all these very left
policies and they call him all right
they call him right wing and it's
because he opposes the establishment
because he says freedom so it really
does show you that it very much is
liberty versus authority when someone
has left as jimmy dore is considered
like a grifter right wing whatever and
it's like
i don't know it's just crazy glenn
greenwald matt tybee mike tracy these
journalists are all called right wing
and they're clearly liberals russell
brand russell brand
was linked to be all right recently
because he started to actually talk
about the science and logically go
through things and explain things better
than almost any other politician and
journalist in this country ever did
you you've got subpoenas
now i think with uh with a durham report
you've got people now saying like oh
like durham's actually investigating and
so russell brandt sees an article where
it's like you know new evidence emerges
in in durham probe and then russell
brand comes out he's like look at this
evidence it's amazing clinton was
actually involved and they're like he's
a crackpot conspiracy theorist now it's
like dude just read a newspaper that's
how insane is so it's it's also a cult
right
one nation controlled by the media isn't
that something incredible now green day
is just basically what establishment
shills yo it was you know you know what
really tripped me out
it was almost like
i felt like i was looking for another
dimension when i saw pen gillette with
gavin newsom and they're like yeah i'm
like
how does libertarian female pleasure
jacuzzi magician guy
stand next to this dude who's an
authoritarian ruling by edict who
doesn't follow his own rules and like
what what happened to people
and he's a health nut right penn
jillette
i mean he used to be overweight and he
lost a bunch of weight he got healthy
maybe he's got some sort of and i don't
know i don't know maybe he sold his soul
to the devil
make me skinny and more famous go to
kiss up to gas of nuisance but okay yeah
i will whatever his name is he's uh he's
filled with a lot of that's kind of say
the least this is the double speak from
1984 where they tell you the ministry of
peace is the one who declares all the
wars and there it's really work you can
see it working on some people yeah i
mean my family fled wit me from
communism we came to the united states
because it represented an idea of
freedom where the government won't
centralize control of everything where
it allows people to earn money it allows
people to have their own businesses it
allows people to have their own space as
long as they're not hurting anyone else
it allows people to say and do whatever
they want without a state threatening to
send them to the gulags and now sadly
that state is slowly reverting back to
what me and my family fled from
communist uh poland and uh i think it's
only going to get worse the nature of
centralization of authority i think
exactly but let's let's let's uh let's
bring it back to earth for people
i want you all to see this story from
the from the new york daily news and i
want to make sure we give you all the
nuance and understanding it
just 10 violations so far under new york
city's vaccine mandate for businesses
10.
it's like the golden the golden chalice
at the end of the rainbow now you could
say it's because everyone fell in line
immediately so there's nothing to
enforce
i don't think that's true let me read a
little bit more to give you the full
nuance and then we will provide you with
witness testimony backing up what i'm
saying now it's not just 10 violations
they also say there were 21 000
inspections so they are actually trying
to enforce this 21 000 yeah inspections
5 800 warnings were administered for
issues related to the vaccine mandate
including failure to post written policy
on premises but failure to post policy
is not the same as actually issuing a
violation to somebody because they
didn't do it
10 means they either are unwilling to or
incapable of enforcing this now let me
ask someone who is uh lives in new york
well you don't live in new york but you
are frequent to new york very often yes
yes have uh tell me what's going on i
mean
i go i go there for weeks at a time and
honestly i haven't seen any business
promoting these mandates that's awesome
i really haven't but i live in you know
like when i when i go there i stay in
old school brooklyn
and
i've never if anything i've seen people
with signs that say you know the whole
you know we don't discriminate with sex
race um gender
uh sexual orientation or and then it
says on the bottom or vaccination status
like i've seen more people putting up
those there was a there was an activist
i retweeted forgive me i forgot your
name but um he he put up these flyers he
was handing them out to businesses and
businesses were like yes yes we'll do
this
and it started that image started with
one like delhi i think was on the upper
west side of new york this is manhattan
and then an activist went around handing
them out and now so you're saying you
see more of those than the other signs i
do i do i see more of that i think that
new yorkers are slowly waking up i mean
finally got rid of cuomo the person
that's
coming coming after him isn't much
better probably probably she's probably
worse actually but
at least they're waking up to some
of the of the the authoritarian you know
you know socialist communist but
everything they're breaking up to it
hearing this story that only there's
only been 10 violations
hearing what you say having been there
and then hearing that people across the
country are attending f joe biden i've
never been more optimistic the uh the
premier of new south wales resigned
obviously for supposedly unrelated not
to covet but when she resigned you see
eruptions of cheering in these
bars and places where people are
watching they the public support for her
is nil well there's also massive
protests all over the world from italy
to france to the united kingdom to
sweden to ireland all parts of the
united states even protests in new york
city where there's even some reports of
blm literally marching with trump
supporters uh and i saw photos of this
and this is an incredible moment this is
really a
unifying moment and we have to
understand this i still want to go to
the backdrop of the last story we talked
about because social media
and and and you know the big
corporations the big monopolies out
there shape our reality they don't want
to show us that there's a lot of
resistance to this they don't want to
show us that there's a lot of protest to
this there's a reason the melbourne
police in australia are trying to block
all helicopter footage of inside of that
city so they can't show the masses of
people that have assembled coming
together to literally stand up against
the utter evisceration of total freedom
and liberty in that country so there is
a movement happening there is a wave
there is an energy
and and it it could go either way it
could go towards a positive way or or a
negative way it could go total
enslavement it could anything happen in
any moment but but this is go time this
is again one of the reasons why i'm here
right now because i see it i i know it
and this is this is the cornerstone
moment right now here luke calls me up
and he's like tim i've been on the show
in a minute and i was like i know he's
like but it's got to that point and i
was like i know and i was like i'll be
there is that the call yeah nice
i want to go no i'm sorry no and then
luke just slams into drive and he and
here we go i was going to say talking
about the cults going back and social
media controlling everything i actually
have a video coming up about
how
if you just look at the psychology of a
cult
it's it's fairly obvious
how they're doing this with young women
again my videos focus on women most of
the time
there's there's five things that cults
focus on one of them is or rather the
people that they go after those who want
to feel validated young women
those seeking an identity
young women
[Music]
those who are more followers not leaders
unfortunately young women yeah which is
why i continuously aim to empower women
um
those who constantly blame others
is not necessarily young women but it's
young people yeah
and people have people and leftists yeah
people are people who have very low
self-worth and people who are very angry
yeah are very easily influenced and
become uh are the most likely people to
be in involved in cultures if they can
make you hate yourself they can they
could change your perception about how
you see yourself they could change your
perception about how you see the world
and that's another gross power that they
have been leveraging that they have been
pushing that they have been manipulating
there's a reason again big tech social
media youtube even twitter facebook who
was their first targets cultural figures
people
independent journalists people that were
providing information people that were
going against the agenda meanwhile there
was isis on the platform there was
taliban on the platform there was people
that were hurting children on the
platform there's people that were
exploiting children
that's not for our safety and then and
now they have the gall to tell you we
need to fight medical disinformation for
your health and safety you're the one
causing people to be depressed you're
the one causing people to commit suicide
you're the one causing people to hurt
each other you're the one literally
causing havoc and pain on the rest of
the world you have this at your
fingertips you know what you're doing
this and you're telling me i can't even
question the medical establishment i
can't even question pfizer that has a
criminal past i i i don't want to get
the show in trouble i got a lot more to
say and you know we can write on fire
all day and night i want to clarify you
say that they're causing it and the
argument they're going to give you is
we're not causing it other people are
doing it and we're just we're just a
platform then why not like the
if you go in the middle of the street
and you sit down and block traffic
you're not doing anything you're just
sitting there but you're actually doing
something passively by blocking traffic
so them not
solving it is them doing it it's not
just that they carefully curate what you
see
they make sure your perception is shaped
by what they want you to see voices that
they don't like that go against their
agenda that go against their narrative
they get censored they get shadow banned
they get demonetized their
infrastructure their businesses their
their way of living literally gets taken
away from them let me let me just let me
just throw some out there so uh we've
got right now watching 41 605 people and
last week when we had on the founder
from library a competitor to youtube boy
were our views down and people were
complaining they couldn't find the
podcast so when you have a store a title
and a video that says like facebook was
taken down which is the title of this
featuring youtuber and youtuber face
youtube's like this is fine there's no
red flags here when you have an episode
where you have the name
of the founder of library libertarian
new hampshire free state project guy all
of a sudden we're just we just no one's
getting notified that we went live and
you see how it's played they don't you
got to be careful
right so so most of you have heard this
from me before but for those who haven't
ebay this is the ebay story i know bear
with me guys for those who haven't heard
it you have you ever heard the ebay
story no so when ebay started it was
yellow this is like maybe this story's
apocryphal but it was yellow and then
one day they said we're gonna make it
white but then all of a sudden all of
their users revolted and they were like
ah it's awful it's too bright i don't
like it make it yellow again so they
change it back but then
every day over the next year they they
ship they shifted it one shade towards
white
then within a year it was a white
website and no one cared facebook
noticed the same thing remember in the
early days facebook would roll out this
update and everyone go wow everything's
all different i don't like it so they
started updating only one thing at a
time for different groups of people so
that people would be like hey did you
notice this change no okay whatever i
guess to stop the shock
that's exactly what they're doing with
censorship especially on youtube and
other platforms so you know i'll we'll
try to use it to the best of our
abilities before it happens but they
don't outright ban people who are having
conversations within the rules they just
make sure certain conversations can't be
heard they'll they'll down rank
conversations that may threaten youtube
and they'll ignore things that they
think has no relevance towards it at all
alex jones of course gets completely
nuked off the platform for what like you
know year-old comments or whatever he
gets sued for decade old comments or
whatever they really go after you if if
you're really actually threatening the
machine and alex jones was influential
he does say a lot of kooky crazy things
he does say a lot of crazy things it
turned to be right but he was
influential in helping trump get support
mike drop
that's what i was going to say about the
frogs
i was gonna say the same thing if you if
you a frog will jump out of the pot if
you put it in boiling water but if you
leave it it'll cook itself if you boil
it slow if you do it slowly it'll cook
itself to death i was thinking the same
thing when you said that someone someone
soup someone super chatted at us saying
that wasn't true i don't know but it's
still it's still a good say it's still a
good concept even if it's not true we've
got because it makes sense we have
people in the super chat who are like
the comic book guy from the simpsons
actually tim the thing about the frogs
isn't true and uh and we accept those
corrections thank you very much good
audience there's also oh i think this
blacklist this social blacklisting i'm
still interested in what you're about to
say there is is devastating and that
they can do it in private is really
unethical oh yeah did people's private
dms private messages that you could like
i could text you on facebook about like
a medication that's on some blacklist
word and then all of a sudden they're
like oh we're going to down rank
crossland's stuff from now on so we're
going to make him see a tenth of the
people 10th of his followers will now
see it instead but i don't know what
happened
that's that's
madly unethical i know they're a private
company but i also know they have 1.8
billion users per day so it's kind of a
common public company as well
well we know what they're censoring but
let's talk about what they're promoting
they're promoting mainstream media trash
they're promoting a lot of garbage
they're promoting a lot of fake news
they're promoting a lot of
disinformation that has been knowingly
corrected that knowingly was brought out
in false pretenses that knowingly misled
the general public that knowingly led to
harm in many instances i mean cnn uh
there's even arguments to make against
fox news msnbc all the major big
channels ran with fake news that had
major implications on people's lives and
existences and they never felt the
ramifications of it i sneezed the other
way and i have to look out to make sure
my video doesn't get uh rated for as an
adult content uh and age restricted uh
because i showed a video of a police
officer being too close to another
person and scaring them i'm like this is
absolutely absurd they play by a
different set of rules and they want to
make sure that you only are able to
listen to the narrative you're only able
to listen to
anderson cooper and
whatever other celebritar do they have
for you that they push in front of you
that is willing to regurgitate their
talking points and do whatever uh
for a paycheck and that's exactly what
we see
i was gonna say i'm living proof of that
i think that i've been making the same
type of content for 10 years on youtube
sexually as sexually explicit as it gets
you know what i mean talking about sex
talking about relationships reviewing
sex toys and stuff
i never once got demonetized by youtube
until i came out as leaning more
conservative on certain issues not once
when did it happen
right after i came out right after i
came out i didn't even come out as
conservative i i came out as leaving the
left that's all that i said i'm no
longer a part of these people i do not
want to be involved with them i think
they're a cult i said that kind of stuff
tim actually helped me write the script
for that thank you tim and sydney um
i i don't i i said i don't want to be a
part of these people's you know
narrative anymore i don't agree with
mostly anything they say and i got
demonetized a month after that and then
and then i was monetized for like three
months and then i got demonetized again
and then i got demonetized again
and for sexually explicit content my
videos got less sexually explicit over
the years so how does that make any
sense let me pull this article this this
article absolutely blew my mind it's
from neiman lab which is like a
journalist you know college
organization how a conservative comic
became the most popular late night host
on tv
gutfeld
fox news the most popular late night
host the funny thing about this
is that they're very clearly leftists
who are trapped in a cult where they
lack the ability to see outside of their
bubble
and they view
greg gutfeld's success as an aberration
on their system
completely oblivious to the fact that i
believe it was jimmy kimmel who did
blackface
when is how that has not never come up
they talk about gutfeld doing edgy jokes
and conservative comedy that the left
would find offensive but the right
doesn't care uh yeah they all used to do
that it's the craziest thing right
gut felt you know here's how i imagine
greg gutfeld and fox news's you know
pitch for the show went down before they
decided to launch it
god failed walks into the office and
they go like hey remember when late
night comedy was funny yes i do okay
here there's the show uh we'll air at
eight go for it that's it
they they they were like we're gonna do
a normal comedy like comedy used to be
before it was woke
do normal things americans like
but late night comedy on the left is
just like vaccine did you see the the
syringe thing with colbert
who watches that they're like i relate
to that i i was embarrassed yeah well
it's like honestly real quick it's like
remember those cartoons you'd watch when
you were a kid about like you must brush
your teeth yes i know you were getting
weird
like in greece in greece when they show
it like in the 1960s on the on the
drive-in theater it's like that
reminded me of you know what i'm talking
about that's why that's what it is but
like adults are watching this yo mike i
think it was mike stern which we tweeted
that boomers are like the first
generation that hadn't moved past
adolescence and i'll tell you this this
next generation that's watching cold
bear as he does these things they're
like permanent children taught like
toddlers i have disliked colbert's art
for
15 years i made a youtube video in 2006
which i'm sure you can find on my
youtube channel where i criticize them
for basically
lying to people with his you know he'd
be like oh i'm playing a character but
he come and be like war is good and he'd
do this like weird conservative
aberration and it was like he would lie
and lie and lie and now he got a new job
as a tonight show host and he's still
trash he's doing the exact same thing
but nobody's left us now well if you
look at his previous show on comedy
central it was actually uh edgy it was
actually somewhat comedic it was
actually kind of ironic satirical he was
playing up this kind of conservative
personality and questioning a lot of the
wars questioning a lot of the security
states questioning a lot of the
intelligence agencies he even brought up
bilderberg he literally like i had
conversations with him about bilderberg
and other very serious legitimate issues
i have those videos still on my youtube
channel luckily but something changed
when he went on the big networks and
he's literally doing big pharma
commercials with dancing needles
promoting
freaking a medical procedure that he
says should be mandatory for everyone to
take jimmy kimball's know better i mean
all of them regurgitate the same talking
points jimmy campbell was literally
trying to make a joke about how people
were in the hospital because of either
uh
of a of a readily available pill that we
can't mention we can talk about it
jimmy kimball was literally spreading
fake news as a joke saying how gunshot
victims couldn't uh have help at a
hospital because everyone there was
overdosed on this uh pill that's readily
available that i don't even know if we
could say on this platform uh in fear of
possibly taking what are the rules for
this channel down i don't know i don't
want to
people know exactly what i'm saying i've
been talking about it since last year by
the way it's ivermectin yeah and
youtube's rule is that you can't
recommend it that you have to inform
people that is not fda approved for the
treat as a treatment for covid and that
you should talk to your doctor about
what's right for you before you know
taking any medications which i i i i
agree with yeah i agree with those
statements right so so it's not like i i
think the issue is that that bothers me
that i haven't complained about is that
you can literally there are people who
go on youtube and say don't talk to your
doctor just go to a parking lot at a
7-eleven i'm not i'm not even right with
that
that's dangerous yes some of the biggest
youtubers are like go down to a local
parking lot where they're doing this and
and i'm like i'm tweeting like hey you
should talk to a doctor man like yeah
and then i love it when the leftists go
that's stupid the doctor would just
recommend the vaccine and i'm like then
why are you mad at me like
okay yeah there's something weird about
them being like don't go to your doctor
like they're mad that i'm telling people
to actually consult medical advice yeah
maybe because they want people to just
walk down to the parking lot without
asking any questions about what their
medical treatment is just listen to the
out of touch politicians that are
working for the corporate heads they
know what's best for you not your
medical doctor and professional because
you know possibly you might have
something like antibodies you might have
a medical condition
you might have an underlining condition
your doctor knows what's right for you
and there's also a purge happening with
a lot of doctors being censored which
also needs to be addressed because when
we're reaching a phase where medical
data studies
professionals experts in the field are
being punished for providing raw data i
mean that's that's such a dangerous time
right now and then and then this is i
don't want to deviate off of the you
know we're talking about i was going to
talk about the the healthcare workers
that were just fired in new york we'll
get into that too i just you know for
those things i don't want to deviate too
hard we're talking about greg godfeld
and colbert and then it starts shifting
a little bit too much i do want to show
you the image so you can understand
we're talking about this is colbert with
dancing syringes called the vax scene
and the weirdest thing is the people who
watch the show are probably all
vaccinated they don't need to see this
and the people who aren't are not going
to be convinced by this weird behavior
that they find strange that's literally
what i thought of when i watched that
that clip i said nobody is gonna nobody
like myself or whoever does it you know
because i had coveted i talked about it
on on a video um no one's being
convinced by nobody nobody on the on the
right or let me let me show you this
real quick i want to read this for you
from the from the neiman lab article
they say hiding in plain sight despite
its growing prominence right-wing comedy
remains largely invisible in both
mainstream and scholarly discussions of
media and humor in part this happened
because social media algorithms don't
send users jokes likely to challenge or
offend their political sensibilities let
me just point something out
i follow mainstream media they talk
about mainstream late night hosts all
the time i follow conservative media
they sometimes will talk about gutfeld
what happens i get a balanced news diet
showing me what the conservatives are
talking about the moderates and the
liberals and liberals in mainstream
media only see what's happening in the
liberal sphere they have no idea what's
happening how how does that manifest you
can really tell if someone's in the cult
an american idiot controlled by the
media when it's it's as simple as you
know like phil defranco coming out and
saying the covington kids were wrong and
bad
when when the covington thing happened
i get sent all these videos like tim
look at this are you angry and i saw the
video i'm like i have no idea what's
happening it was just a picture of a it
was a video of a kid with like a drum in
his face and he's like smirking or
whatever and i'm like
what's happening but people just
immediately like it's bad because we
said so even people were supposed to be
doing news and then i started looking at
the live streams and immediately like i
made a video saying the media is lying
about the covington kids they didn't do
anything wrong and then all of a sudden
one by one all these new news
outstanding issuing corrections and
updates but you can easily just look at
the the personalities even on youtube or
whatever who are in the cult and not
paying attention to what's happening
outside of their bubble and and the
crazy thing is they're getting angrier
and angrier like i'll bring up phil
defranco again because i used to think
he was awesome i was like there's a
right he's an independent entrepreneur
then all of a sudden he's tweeting how
he hates people and he wishes harm on
them and i'm like whatever is in that
cult bubble is becoming increasingly
angry and violent echo chamber we also
have to realize these people see a
different news feed than we do these
people are curated information that's
regurgitated that they want to hear
again and again um and and by and large
late night television is dominated by
the same neoliberal corporatist uh big
totalitarian talking points except for a
few deviations one of the most
significant ones that uh is very
prominent to me is the guy who looks
like my dad bill maher he does an
excellent job
and and i don't always agree with him i
don't always agree with him but i think
he does provide some kind of context
that does deviate from the agenda the
narrative and he does start an
interesting conversation even though i
don't agree with his opinion on the
conversation at least he starts one we
gotta lose
he's doing a little better he's doing a
little better but bill maher was also
wrong on the covington kids yeah a week
of course a week after the corrections
bill maher came out and was like what's
up with that and it's like dude you're a
weak like they've already issued
corrections on this
i talked about it you know seven days
before he came out
and did a show but i will give him the
respect for at least standing up and
saying this is going too far what's
happening to this country and now you
know what really was the bridge making
breaking the the the bridge breaking or
the strawberry and the camelback camel's
back is bill maher issuing a quote where
he's like i'm getting attacked for
criticizing the left too much
ding ding ding ding there it is bill
maher smart guy all of a sudden you're
starting to realize the republicans
aren't doing anything they're sitting on
their hands the waste of our time they
act like they're supporting us they
don't do anything i don't care for them
oh i like what i hear like oh that's a
good agenda i'm school choice sounds
great and then what do they do nothing
the democrats meanwhile are like we're
going to burn it down so what are your
options bill maher all of a sudden is
chris has on the left because the right
the republican establishment does
nothing oh bill maher could rag on
marjorie taylor green but i'm sure bill
marston they're like she's a freshman
congresswoman why do i care
well if you want to pile along with the
establishment that's the target he's
like an observant uh comedian that talks
about the news but i don't think he's
ever claimed to be a journalist or
anything like that of course not yeah
well he has a late night show that he
does every friday night and he does have
people like ben shapiro on i have a lot
of things to criticize ben shapiro on
but at least there's another voice from
a different spectrum compared to of
course stephen colbert jimmy kimball
that have the same nonsense again over
again spreading fake news spreading this
information spreading i mean that story
about the hospital being overrun with
people uh from poison control uh that
was another in oklahoma in oklahoma i
mean that story has ramifications that
story could actually hurt people that
story uh is having real life
consequences i mean imagine someone in
the third world country who's taken that
specific medicine for the specific use
of saying hey i don't want my you know i
don't want to be poisoned because of
this hold on it's ridiculous i want to
elaborate on that so there was a story
that went around from large mainstream
leftist publications that ivermectin was
sterilizing men
now imagine so ivormectin is used to
treat river blindness a parasite in the
eyes it is not fda approved for for
treating kovid but in africa it is
considered an essential medication by
the u.n imagine you you have a country
right when they got ebola
in in north africa
you had people
fleeing quarantine thinking that these
people were coming in and infecting them
or killing them or harming them
so they would literally like take ebola
infected bodies and run and then it
would get worse it would spread now
imagine you have these people in these
villages it is mostly rural african
tribes that have river blindness and
along comes the u.n saying we want to
give you this medication to cure you of
your blindness
and then they're like they they hear
these stories but on the internet in
america they say it takes away our
ability to have children it sterilizes
us either that's the most psychotic
conspiracy theory i've ever heard or
these people are more crimes against
humanity
look i think you are posting that
information is a crime against humanity
my point is the un is not sterilizing
small poor african tribes they're trying
to cure them of river blindness i'm not
a big fan of the un and and their
ineffective you know whatever it is
they're doing for the most part but when
they're like we're gonna cure every
blindness i'm like sounds about right
that's what iver mechan does and then
the media comes out with and it also
sterilizes men because it was like a
study of 30 people and like eight had
reproductive issues and now you're going
to have the you have the risk of
misinformation freaking people out and
bringing back river blindness that's the
crime against humanity yes posting the
misinformation well if you go on the nih
website and you look at the medical
studies surrounding ivermectin
especially even the preliminary ones i
don't want to get this channel in
trouble but just do your own research do
your own homework and look at the
medical studies and make up your own
decisions and have those serious
conversations with your medical
professionals it's it's as simple as
you know look there's a lot of people
who are like oh the the censorship yes i
will say it right now
there are certain medications you two
will ban you for recommending and others
they expect you to recommend no no i
don't play any of that game i don't give
financial advice medical advice or legal
advice and if you and when people
message me all the time saying oh but my
doctor's not smart my doctor's bad i'm
like then you've got a bad doctor man i
have to say it over and over again
people are probably saying tim you've
told us this 50 times i know but i got a
super chat last week saying the exact
same thing where they're like but i have
a dumb doctor i'm like why why not go to
a doctor that isn't dumb have you
considered that i mean you're paying for
it one way or another either through
your taxes or your insurance you're
paying for that medical care i don't
know why people think that medical care
is you know
something that they're giving to you
that's that's voluntary it's not you're
paying for it in one way or another and
and when we look at our history
especially in the medical field they
have failed us time and time again and
it's important to note especially with
the opioid epidemic we had very serious
problems very serious ramifications from
medical professionals uh being bought
out and lying to people giving them
medications that they knew was bad for
them uh being given false information
having criminal activities that were
literally
done by many medical professionals
literally making people heroin addicts
all over this country well tuskegee even
biome brought it up the the tuskegee
experiments right that's it so it's like
look man a healthy individual is is
skeptical but not overly distrustful
they they try to get by they try to do
some research but ultimately we'll try
to trust the experts and it's a very
very difficult and narrow path to figure
out but there's personal responsibility
in there but let me pull up this story
right here this is big we got this from
forbes
new york's largest health care provider
fires 1 400 employees who refuse to get
vaccinated can i just say that
firing health care uh employees during a
pandemic sounds like not a good idea
it's like a bad idea maybe yep that was
the first that was the first thought
that that crossed my mind and my and my
cousin's a nurse and she worked with
covet patients and she said the same
thing she said this is this is
disgusting to do to these people they
were called our heroes we were literally
uh
hitting pots and pans outside supporting
them and now they're literally being
kicked to the streets with a caveat
because a lot of the people who are
being fired are being denied
unemployment benefits as another
draconian step by the new york state
that is going out of their way to make
sure that people can't have enough money
to feed their families to feed their
loved ones and and this health care
provider it was the northwell health
company 1 400 people will go with
with with with a situation where they
can't pay the bills
i got a friend
very very you know pro joe biden
anti-trump the whole time screaming
ignoring the riots your typical
establishment liberal type just pro
corporate chill and boy was it funny
when they started posting on facebook
how they're terrified the vaccine
mandates are here i'm gonna lose my job
i can't believe this is wrong why are
they doing this and i'm like bro you
voted for it yeah you voted for you
asked for this yeah like you got i got
to say i feel bad and i also want to
laugh at the same time i'm like to see
the cathartic it's the cathartic release
of like everything you were saying was a
lie i told you it was a lie now here you
are frantic
but i feel bad because the whole point
of me opposing this stuff was so that my
friends wouldn't be dealing with this
but boy
you know i'm sure everybody knows some
of these people that just won't listen
you know why
because the demoralization is complete
as yuri besmanov said you can show them
the true and correct authentic authentic
information and they will not accept it
another thing to really consider here is
that these are medical professionals on
the front lines these are the people
that helped cure people with covet these
are the people administering the vaccine
these are the people that were literally
on the front lines if there's any
experience that these people have if
there's any thoughts that these people
have we should be listening to them we
should have a conversation with them we
should not throw them to the streets and
that's exactly what new york state is
doing in a two-tier society that is now
here and it's disgusting to see our you
know heroes medical workers that are
volunteering
many times working overtime helping
people in their worst states now being
thrown to the streets well that being
said i wonder how many of these people
got fired were dancing in the hallways
and you know that kind of stuff probably
not these people in particular but uh at
the same time look there's a lot of
criticism to go around for a lot of
these people too who went out from their
new york health you know care facilities
went out in the street clapping and
cheering for black lives matter and like
who were openly defying coveted lockdown
measures so
and we're saying that black lives matter
protests were actually good for kovid
and stopping the spread and counter
protests were not i want to i want to
ask you luke because uh last week when
we had shane cashman on the show he said
something really interesting to me and
i'm curious what your thoughts on this
too he said new york has already seceded
they've already you need a passport to
go there right if you don't have the
required you need a physical card proof
to actually use the services of new york
as if it were a different country and if
you don't have what's required on the
card which is not just your vaccines
your identification as well you it used
to be in new york you could walk into
any place and buy whatever you wanted
now you need an id and your your your
vaccine passport so he was like
they've implemented rules already that
have basically excised half the
population from able to go there that's
like soft seating as it is exactly it's
it's a different society that plays by
different rules compare new york to
florida new york the uh i mean florida
the case numbers dropped according to
some estimates even 95 percent uh and
when you go to florida the restaurants
are open stadiums are open schools are
opens there's no restrictions there's no
lockdowns there's no two-tier society
there's no papers please everywhere you
go so so we're seeing something that is
slowly spreading west virginia is the
same give us some credit well it depends
also where you go there's liberal cities
uh everywhere even in florida like in
tampa they're trying to implement uh vax
passports as well that needs to be
called out and uh and they're fighting
with the state so so there's there's
different people pushing different
things but if you remember one of the
first things that i brought up last year
the first time i went on this show was
the need for a peaceful divorce uh a
divorce between the statists and the
people who actually believe in personal
freedom and personal liberty now we talk
about it almost every single day well so
so but let's you were saying that new
york you're not even noticing any of
these things no no but i agree with what
you say and i want to comment on that
because i was with my friend
my friend sarah who
uh served in the army for five years and
then came out as transgender and now
she's living her best life as a woman um
she said it the best we were we were
traveling from nashville which was super
liberal to north carolina which was more
conservative we saw the differences just
from driving from state to state and the
way she explained it was was really well
put she's like you know what at this
point i don't care about california
anymore if they want socialism let them
have it because i don't live there
that's the way she put it i mean she
they voted for that i don't live there i
i she's like we tried we tried to
explain to them that this isn't gonna
work it's never worked and she's like
it's the united states is in a very
interesting situation because we have 50
different states for that reason because
each of those states needs has different
needs and has different laws because
that's the way we were designed yeah um
and it's interesting it will be
interesting to see what flourishes and
what fails
and i think right now
from the for the most part i think
california and new york city are failing
52 percent of biden of trump support
trump voters want peaceful divorce 41 of
biden voters we're getting close yeah
but the biden administration is bailing
out new york and california giving them
everyone's tax dollars uh financing a
lot of their sanctuary cities financing
a lot of their insane policies financing
just the the the total marxist and again
if marxists want to live in in communism
i don't want to stop you from doing that
but stop forcing other people to do it
as well i lived in new york city we
actually lived very close to each other
we didn't know each other like this the
first time yeah we were actually
schoolmates which is pretty interesting
uh but but
i left i said i'm done i'm done
incentivizing my taxes uh i don't want
them going here it's unethical it's
immoral for my taxes to be going here my
energy my time my social circle it was
hard to end all that i literally went up
to new hampshire no plan and i became a
part of the free state project and i
love it there and i love coming down
here i love being in florida and i love
incentivizing and voting with my actions
what i personally like and i think if we
need to
do anything it's to be aware of the
small decisions that we make every day
in our existence because those decisions
matter the most and they mean the most
as far as impact because again they
could only get away with this if we
allow it to get away with it you can't
comply your way out of tyranny it's not
going to happen uh and what's happening
in new york california is absolutely
tyrannical you want to live under it you
love it stay there i would love this to
instead of referring to these cities as
liberal just start referring to them as
authoritarian because i'm a liberal i'm
very liberal in my behavior i'm not a
liberal i'm just super liberal i like
liberal with sexuality liberal with what
you do with your life you know
libertarian is liberal i mean that's the
same freaking root and yeah i hate that
they took that word from us i really do
because we are we are so we call it
classic liberals classical liberals are
like
classical liberalism is a center right
position that means towards no it's
always been oh yeah that leans towards
libertarianism and then what we refer to
as traditional liberals is actually
social liberal so like i've actually
read you know a little bit different
writers about social liberalism versus
classical liberalism they're very much
the same and that's that's how it used
to be it used to be classical liberalism
versus uh social liberalism where you
have social liberals saying this was
like the civil rights movement hey the
state needs to stop this and the
classical liberals were like private
businesses can do what they want live
and let live yeah now it's the
democrats that are actually the ones
saying private corporations do what they
want the problem is these are massive
multinational billion dollar
unaccountable corporations so they're
basically fascists yeah when social
liberalism goes too far you get
authoritarianism when you have the state
trying to enforce civil rights that's a
form of authoritarianism very small
amount to do some good but if it goes
too far and then you start to force
people to take medicine and force people
to stand this way and say this thing
that's madly authoritarian and very
dangerous you know i'd say it was a
slippery slope but i think it's a sheer
cliff right what we're what we're on and
you know luke was saying like we're on
the precipice and i'm kind of like uh we
went off it we went off the press you
know i wound up like we're just falling
now i wanted to mention the you you
mentioned the 50 was the 52 percent of
trump odors wanted to secede in 41 of
but that actually comes from a poll the
daily mail posted it where they've only
pulled 2012 people and then they
extrapolated 2012 people to the entire
united states and the the name the
headline is america thinks the
unthinkable more than half of trump
voters want red and blue states to
succeed they only pulled two thousand
people slow down a thousand trump voters
let's let's slow down for a second
that's actually a pretty large sample
size 2012 people out of 350 million yes
that's not large that it is it's a large
sample size for a poll maybe yes but
it's a terrible way to frame just
because a 2 000 person polls that more
than half of the trump voters want right
i'm so i'm explaining to you as much as
i'm not a fan of a lot of these polls
and don't trust them
standards for polling that's actually
crap standards and we got to talk about
now you can have a poll that's
disingenuous and you can have a poll
that's misframed and this has been
misframed well i don't think it's
miserable it says that more than half of
the trump voters want it and they only
pulled a thousand of them
that's that's that's how they they made
a claim about 80 million people based
off of a poll of a thousand people i i
understand your argument but there's no
point in continuing if you don't know
how the polls well i'm saying that it's
a dangerous precedent to allow people to
frame polls like this the problem with
polling is that they'll say something
like this like let me ask you a question
ariel do you think that we should use
some of our tax dollars towards
green energy so that we can you know
make the air cleaner and and our and our
you know our water cleaner sure okay let
me ask you another question do you think
that we should have a massive government
overhaul an increase in taxes
restricting what private businesses can
do
no okay you're for and against the grain
right yeah exactly it's the way you
frame it yeah the question you asked
we'll get someone so we'll say like we
asked you know now
polls typically release their
questionnaire so they don't do that as
overtly the problem with political
polling is that they'll always interview
more democrats the problem isn't the
sample size
a 500 is a bad sample size but what they
do is they target regions
they'll go into certain areas with
certain voting demographics and they'll
look at the age the breakdown and then
they'll take a sample of those people
and use them as a representative sample
it's not just 2000 random people it is
it is it and you can look at the the um
i forgot i'm forgetting the word you can
look at actually how they calculated
this they'll show you all the math
they'll show you all the questions
that's actually not bad 2000. now you
need to check the question they asked
but it seems like that actually tracks
with other data we've seen where 37.2
percent of voters in general from
independents not just uh republicans and
democrats 37.2 want their region to
break off and form its own country
okay but this is like if you asked the
four of us in the room a question no it
isn't it is but okay a thousand so yeah
you grabbed two thousand people too we
can't just keep listen to me you bring
the 2000 people into a room and you ask
them to a poll and then you say half of
all people think that it's not that's
not what you did you pulled 2 000 people
ian you need to stop okay we're going to
move on i definitely want to move on
because
you need to read how polls work i know
how polls work they pulled 2012 people
and then said that it was half of the
people okay and talk about something
else read about polls we'll come back to
this
so uh
anyway
the country wants to break apart no no i
disagree i don't know where you're
getting that info i think i i think i
think they do i think we feel a
sentiment of of of dissatisfaction i
think a lot of people i mean if you look
at the dissatisfaction rate amongst
congress members everyone's dissatisfied
with what congress is doing now people
are satisfied with what their local
congressman is doing there's polls
suggesting that but overall i think
we're down a trajectory towards an
extremely bad path i think everyone that
knows it government has been standing in
the way of free enterprise capitalistic
endeavors that have been creating such
an economic bubble that it's about to
burst and pop any time and we are about
to be put right into a situation i think
akin to the great depression
especially with the financial mess that
we are all involved in with the federal
reserve literally just printing money
out of thin air i think the financial
calamities are going to be far more
impactful than the health aspects that
we're even dealing with right now and i
think a crash is coming and when that
happens oh boy will things get worse and
the agenda will be pushed through even
more let me ask you guys do you think
that the crash is going to result in
prop and prices collapsing or
skyrocketing inflation or deflation it's
it's too hard to tell right now to be
honest with you because of so much
supply shortages so much labor short
inflation um and and when we look at
what the government's doing now i mean
they're purposefully making it that much
worse they're putting restrictions on
the ports so products can't get here
there's there's labor unions screaming
at the governments please stop stop with
your insanity stop with your madness add
that on top of labor shortages federal
mandates increasing the labor shortages
states like new york and california
farmers being told to destroy their
crops destroy their livestock we are
headed down a disastrous path and their
only way to get out of it without being
hurt is by having people break up into
their own personal individual little
units a lot of people like to group up
republicans democrats it doesn't matter
to me i think it's beyond that it's
freedom slavery which one do you believe
in and and that's that's the law that's
the line you want to live in communism
go live there uh you want to live in
freedom you want to have your own
personal choices for yourself it's
already happening people that that don't
like communism or moving out of new york
are moving out of california and they're
incentivizing states that's why there's
a whole migrant crisis on the border
because they're trying to counter that
by bringing in as many new voters as
they can as well i disagree with that
these these uh illegal immigrants that
are coming in are being shipped all over
the country exactly but they're not
they're not i don't think they're going
to get a path of citizenship in the
immediate exactly it's going to be a
long time for now but what you need to
understand congressional seats though
exactly so
this let me let me tell you this because
you might not might not know this ariel
the way we do electoral college votes
for the president is based on how many
congressional seats a state has
a state's congressional seats are based
on the amount of people there not
citizens which means if a million
illegal immigrants come into texas which
we've seen
that means we need to give texas one
more congressional seat even though
those people aren't citizens wow that
means texas will get another electoral
college vote so they're not directly
voting in a popular vote but but they're
still they're still yeah they're still
changing elections yep wow no i didn't
know that yep
so that's yeah that's that's definitely
a possibility you know tucker carlson
was like they're going to give them a
path of citizenship so they can vote
because they always vote democrat and
i'm like they don't need to they need to
only move them into the specific suburbs
or states so they find blue so they send
them to blue states so but however
census just happened so they have to
wait 10 years for this take effect but
that's what will happen bring in as many
people as possible into blue states to
get more seats and there you go you can
you can then gain advantage
politics is all about just gaining power
they don't care how they do it they just
want to do it that's what's happening as
dianne feinstein is telling you you need
a passport permission slip just to fly
domestically inside of the united states
that's the bill that you literally
propose or a negative test or proof of
recovery
how do you prove recovery yeah
yeah so negative tests right they're
they're they're increasing the mandates
and it is really really interesting that
all of these kind of just feel like it's
like all part of something that feels
like a like a great
re-restart a great reason a great reset
yes i heard that somewhere i heard that
a great researcher a lot of times yep
now we were talking about this last year
there's a big agenda the 2030 agenda you
will have no privacy you will own
nothing you will be happy they took down
they took that website down from the
world economic forum
there's a viral video on twitter where
it's like what life will be like in 2030
you will own nothing and you will be
happy and then everyone started tweeting
it like dude look what they're saying
and then they deleted it last year i
still remember we were at the skate park
outside in the garage and i was like you
won't believe this the pope mastercard
and other multinational corporations are
coming together to try to usher in the
great reset officially
officially saying we need to change the
way things we was like economically and
no i'm serious and then it was
mainstream media news uh it wasn't even
me just you know speculating a lot of
this stuff but but again it's it's all
there it's it's all in everything that
they have prophesied that they have been
talking about they've been talking about
doing this through global warming for
such a long time the same
implementations the same things that
they called for are being implemented
and and that we're seeing the same
policies being instituted not just here
domestically in the united states but as
if it was a coordinated plan
internationally turkey just launched
domestic passport systems on planes
trains and buses to travel domestically
you need to have a vaccine passport
israel has done the same italy has done
the same france is going to be
instituting those laws when just a few
weeks ago we were told that vaccine
passports were conspiracy theories
you're crazy if you think there's going
to be vaccine passports joe biden even
told the national television no way
we're going to have vaccine mandates
what do you think like one implemented
one big tv in the nation's capital the
national television well you know what i
mean you know what i'm trying to say
here i'm just looking for i'm just
riffing here off the top of my head i
got a bloomberg opinion article give
amazon and facebook a seat at the united
nations this is from yesterday yeah yeah
from ben shot oh it's i told you might
as well
officials the clown
corporation's governments yeah yeah they
already are this is what we're we're
trying to make people understand what is
governing
one thing you're not considering in all
of this is that
mark zuckerberg is just so cool oh yeah
he's just a really cool truth
truth and jeff bezos that's true oh the
best so cool
i always liked mark zuckerberg me too
you see that 1997 interview with jeff
jeff
bezos you know it'll be funny if there's
like fresh faced he's like in you have
you seen the picture of him in that
crappy little office
it'd be funny if like he's interviewed
and they're like so what's your plans
like well i'm going to sell books and
then uh in 20 years i'll take over the
world
and make a space the truth is shaped
like those guys
those guys those guys are pretty cool
but authoritarian corporations cannot be
considered governments in this world we
cannot allow that to happen i don't care
who's in charge no human can handle that
corporations are people my friend
exactly also truth according to law
although it makes no sense according to
mitt romney i think it's legal they're
legally persons aren't they corporations
well they're i guess they're legal
entities but personhood means like they
can be sued and they function i guess
but i think people wait overestimate
what that means if you say a corporation
has personhood or something it just
means you can sue them and they operate
as though you know a tax entity or
whatever from huffington post
corporations are people and they have
more rights than
oh yeah they can't go to prison
yeah sure enough what if when a
corporation broke the law they you know
put the corporation in prison so it
couldn't operate for a certain amount of
time like a regular person you could do
that digitally i would imagine you shut
the company down okay your company's
effectively shut down and they'll say
but that'll destroy my company don't
think it's funny when you send someone a
prison for five years they come out five
years culturally stunted and often don't
know i don't have skills for jobs yeah
what do you think happens when you send
people to prison when you type in
largest criminal settlement on google
yes i did that earlier today first
article that comes up is a justice.gov
link about the justice department
announcing the largest health care fraud
settlement in its history going after
pfizer that agreed to pay out 2.3
billion dollars a part of the largest
health care fraud settlement in history
of the department of justice and they
were they pled guilty to charges
relating to promoting they're not now
withdrawn uh bextra pain medicine yeah
but but hey hey uh you know stephen
colbert dances and says that's good so
it has to be good yeah
youtube would take direction from a cdc
that's taking direction from pfizer is
disturbing to me that any corporation
would follow this train of command when
you see pfizer one of the 10 largest
criminal fines in history this company
what position at halliburton did dick
cheney have oh god was he the ceo
i'm pretty sure he was uh the ceo and
then what job did he get afterwards vice
presidency of the united states and then
what did the united states do after he
got elected give extremely lucrative
contracts to
give inadequate services to u.s military
men that were serving this country in
iraq and afghanistan that led them
astray and charged them to the highest
degree that they could
well you win the million dollar million
dollars luke
this my bitcoin address is
linked on we are change. tony snap
and then i guess you know you know
what's funny is we have to talk about
politics being downstream from culture
but i think the corporations finally
realized that too like republicans are
still fighting these political battles
like judges and supreme court
the corporations and the democrats uh
well i should say the corporations and
their leashed lap dogs the democrats and
their leashed lap dogs their voter base
have just gone for the cultural
institutions and that's why you know you
see what you see with like the wokeness
on youtube that's why if you deviate
from it even though you have the same
principles you always had they have to
come after you because you need to fall
in line i'm doing i'm going down the
list of the ten largest criminal fines
in history number eight is facebook with
five billion number six is google with
9.5 billion
wow bank of america is on there but it's
also important to note here that this is
a slap on the wrist to how much money
these multinational corporations make i
mean pfizer look how much money they're
making right now they're creating more
billionaires than any other industry
than any other private company in the
world right now as we're speaking right
now with their ceo literally going on
national media and his voice is gospel
couple months ago he told us take the
shot everything will go back to normal
now he's telling us well you're going to
need a booster shot and then maybe we'll
go back to normal and then everyone's
literally regurgitating it as well so
wait wait wait medical
corporate
auto technocracy
yeah
commune
brave new world yeah there you go no
it's not it's it's all of them
bravery world 1984 no it's it's a brave
new 1984 for vendetta and then that new
uh movie that came out on amazon
a brave new fahrenheit 1984 for vendetta
and then what was that movie that they
uh stopped the second season utopia
so here you wanna you know what i
tweeted earlier best one ever i said
a tech billionaire concerned with
overpopulation
uh schemes a plan
to trick people into purging themselves
to save the planet
that is the plot of kingsmen and utopia
and utopia the the evil villain
literally makes fake meat
but watch kingsman it's like it's what
is this have you seen kingsman no so
samuel l jackson plays a tech
billionaire
who makes uh spoilers people haven't
seen it as an older movie but it's like
he's a few years old it's awesome
he makes sim cards for free everyone get
free cell service free internet hey
guess what who else has tried to offer
up free internet around the world couple
tech millions anyway he offers up this
thing and then what it does is
it ran at a certain point when he
activates it it makes every phone emit a
noise that inhibits people's like
judgment so they become violent and
irrational start attacking and killing
each other and he does it and he
explicitly says the earth is got a
thickness because he is a lisp
and he's like and and the planet is
overheating to kill the virus and so his
plan as a tech billionaire is to trick
everyone to taking these sim cards so
that they all will kill themselves and
depopulate the planet
utopia
have you ever seen utopia
utopia got cancelled and my
understanding is got cancelled because
it freaked people out because utopia is
about a tech mogul who's concerned about
overpopulation so he tries making fake
meat and when that isn't working and
advocating isn't changing people's minds
he orchestrates a fake pandemic
to trick people into taking a vaccine
that actually sterilizes them and in the
show
someone who is involved in the project
is giving clues in the form of a comic
two comics dystopian utopia and then
these conspiracy theorists find it and
they're like together look what this
comic is showing us is going to happen
and the funny thing is in our reality
tv show no there's a tv show
in our reality it's a tv show called
utopia telling us that a tech mogul who
makes fake meat is concerned about
overpopulation so he's trying to get
people fixed and sterilized another
layer deep dan bird plays ian who i did
a tv show with dan bird called aliens in
america
i was on the the pilot episode with dan
but he plays a character named ian in
utopia i don't think the tv shows are
real i'm just saying how this is a
singularity is that yeah we're in a
simulation man
let me let you you want you don't know
about the simulation
let me tell you about the simulation all
right
i went to we went to the casino this
weekend listen to this listen to this
story hear me out hear me out we went to
the casino this weekend
and i went uh we played we had a good
time we usually go you like look you
never go to a casino try and win big you
go with like 100 bucks to play some
table games and laugh and you get all
excited and then when you're done you're
done
so i didn't realize the casino out
here's horse racing and they were doing
the horse race and i got to watch the
horse's race it was so cool and so i was
like okay i'll play some bets they're
like two bucks and so i play some bets
ended up winning 57 well the nice old
lady who advised me who to bet uh on
because i didn't know i said i'll give
you a tip here's 20 bucks i got 37 what
am i going to do i'm going to go the
roulette table i'm going to put 35 bucks
on 26.
so i walk up to the roulette table and
there's this guy standing in front of me
not playing and i'm sitting there like
what am i going to do am i going to be
that guy who's like excuse me if you're
not playing can i get in you're in my
way
uh
i'll i'll i'll i'll wait
the lady spins the ball
26 comes up
i was i was so pissed off 26 fine it
came up and i could have been excuse me
sir and then i could have put it down on
20 on 26 and i would have won i think
you know like a grand or something
because i was just like yeah we'll do
26.
so that that pissed me off then i went
to the next roulette table because i
didn't actually play yet and i'm with
allison and with my brother and i'm like
okay i'll put on 26.
i'm the roulette wheel what number is
next to 26
30 and what comes up
30. and not only did 30 come up but the
ball spun and then synchronized with the
wheel and was stuck hovering for a few
seconds and i'm like what is happening
and then it goes right next to 26 and
i'm like oh and and the dealer looks at
me he's like yeah and then it goes 30
and it was ah
now here's what happens next
so we end up coming back because we
wanted to like let's bring people to the
horse races you get like a hot dog you
watch the horses and they weren't doing
live races so we were like oh we should
have checked the brochure but this time
i was like i'm going to go play i'll
play roulette again this time i'll bet
on 26.
so i bet a couple hundred bucks
i'm putting on 26 and the surrounding
numbers
and then i'm like i'm down i'm down and
down but then finally 26 hits i win big
because i had like 25 bucks on it plus i
put bets on everything related to it so
26 is black it's even it's on the middle
rail and then so i win this huge number
and then as the dude is preparing the
chips he walked because it was a digital
one where you can watch them spin but
then he walks over to me and right as he
hands me the chips
26 black hits twice in a row
and then everyone starts laughing and
the dealer goes 26 again
and then i was just like
we live in a simulation
i don't really mean we live in a
simulation i'm just saying like what a
weird weekend magnetic universe that's
for sure i actually don't i actually
believe in that i do believe in that
stuff i am a law of attraction believing
type of person and i think there's there
is science that
that supports a lot of it yeah big rose
quartz crystal right there i do believe
in that stuff i don't think it's
perfectly science but i do i do believe
i i think that's also how people are
they're using the law of attraction to
make people afraid they're continuously
talking about negative things on the
news and continuously talking about
covenant that's all people think about
it and it makes them afraid we're
negative all the time that's that's why
we did chelsea
i think you're critical i think that's
different than being negative but hold
on that's why we started the cascastle
vlog first yeah which is like puppies
playing and the chickens running around
doing chicken stuff and they're really
funny to create something that would
like counterbalance the content
negativity and then we details from the
inverted world because that's not as
upbeat fantasy well no it's real oh
jerusalem it's all true stories well you
just posted i didn't watch it yeah yeah
yeah all true stories investigative
paranormal stuff and that's to inspire
on the universe yes we want people to
hear that and like reinvigorate their
light for like discovery and exploration
so we don't want it just to be doing
negative news all the time i think
there's a big difference especially with
us just recently talking about the mass
movement of people waking up the large
protest compared to the mainstream media
that literally hopes death rates go up
so their counter goes up and they can
make it big and as read as possible cnn
so cnn literally did that right and they
were literally getting off and hoping
that the numbers would be higher to have
generating busters he said and that's
that's shout out to james james o'keefe
and project veritas for getting those
videos out yep
there's a big difference between what
we're doing and what they're doing right
it's not all negative there's a lot of
people out there that are waking up
there's a lot of solutions just waking
up to the problem is the first step in
making the right decisions for yourself
and that gut felt segment was pretty
positive look we got we got greg
gutfeld's you know uh dominating the
late night that's fantastic we've got
people across the country chanting f joe
biden hey it's a good week huh not all
bad and i think neutral energy is
underrated you can be super critical and
be neutral about it grey jedi yeah i
even saw delete facebook trending uh
yeah and a lot of people talking about
it so maybe we could warn people to make
sure that they don't give a phone with
facebook to their adolescent child you
know that's important how about we do
super chats if you haven't already smash
that like button get your super chats in
now we're going to read a whole bunch of
your comments about what you think's
happening and go to timcast.com become a
member because there will be a members
only segment coming up after the show
usually around 11 or so p.m plus we have
a huge library of content already with
like hundreds of videos so definitely
subscribe to this channel smash that
like button let's read
squishy blue says have you ever seen the
anime psycho pass dystopian future where
you're arrested or killed
uh
or arrested not if you've committed a
crime but if you're likely to be based
on your stress level measured by a
machine
oh man i have not reminds me of that
doctor who where they go to the planet
where the robots have the smiley faces
on their screens and if you're not
smiling they kill you
because sadness spreads like a virus so
to prevent sadness from spreading they
kill anyone who's sad which makes more
sadness and so they're walking around
like smiling
yeah crazy
we have a super chat from ian crossland
rodkowski in the house
nice thank you ian nice thank you ian
you're welcome luke i'm glad you're back
waffle sensei is angry says change your
effing shirt to my mind is breaking
ah here we are never summer says let's
go brandon yes brandon i love brandon
let's go brandon
so the way newsweek framed it was that
the reporter was trying to to to play it
off like to trick the audience
i'm missing out did i miss this thing
who's brandon
who's brandon we don't even know no i
don't know the guy who won the race oh
that's right brandon brown okay i wasn't
i only saw the eight second clip of it
the crowd was chanting f joe biden while
they were interviewing this guy brandon
and she's like wow how do you feel
they're chanting let's go brandon
got it yeah and newsweek is like nbc
reporter tries you know damage control
as people chant f joe biden
that was amazing that's really funny
let's see rekra morrison
lemniscape says you talk about fusion a
lot did you ever consider what would
happen if we if if one random guy
figures out cheap fusion
i think a kid did it in his bedroom a 14
year old and they came and shut it down
bobby dial says lucas where is the salt
lamp
um i have it in my videos every video i
have a salt lamp in there you go oh yeah
taylor wilson is the guy's the kid's
name he built the fusion generator at
the age of 14. i do have to get a new
light bulb because it hasn't turned on
recently it's been a while i've been so
busy produced nuclear fusion i don't
know if he probably wasn't ignited we
have these things they're they're
they're a little like plates with an led
in them and you put it on top and it
lights it up so you can just change them
out that's cool
alessio de monte says the way luke
started his intro i thought for a second
it was alex jones circa 2012.
now that's a good episode is that an is
that is that a criticism or i don't know
we do have a past
jenkins leroy
says this one is for ariel as a bisexual
seeing your content along with the
collabs with mike mgtv helped me
understand and accept my sexuality so
much thank you i hope you and him are
still friends acquaintances ah we are
yeah he's one of the people that
actually stayed friends and stayed
friends with me thank god
him and mac yeah who was actually a
friend of yours who is actually a friend
of mine who's uh yeah who might not
agree i don't know what he thinks about
politics i don't even talk to him about
that but yeah he's
he hasn't unfollowed me he hasn't been
spreading rumors as far as i know and
yeah he's one of the one of the few
people yeah he's but you know what he's
a jersey boy and he's an italian and so
he talks generally well generally
speaking italians especially from new
york and new jersey even though we get a
lot of [ __ ] but
we tend to be very loyal people we tend
to be very good friends yeah gino fess
says at ian what's the latest on the
timcast.com social network
oh yeah yeah well
the idea is we're building out the
fetiverse and a social networking
package but what i want to do is start
building free software on like a secret
dot io site where we can start
implementing all our free software and
then maybe one day we'll open up an open
beta for people to test it and then down
the line that can become the tim cast
model and then we'll set that up but
that's that's a far way off but i'll
definitely let you know as we start
building it out cool
kyle miller says this facebook
whistleblower that was on 60 minutes
feels like a plant so there's an excuse
to censor fb in the internet
yeah i mean what she literally came out
and said she got a job at facebook to
make sure she could censor conspiracy
theories like that's your first worry
that that's everything that's going on
that's your big worry some some guys
sharing his theories on things come on
it's ridiculous
judge 1964 cpu says hey tim long time
listener and lover of your content i
want to shout out against i shouted
against my company covanta energy for
implementing biden's illegal vaccine
mandates they admitted that in the
company email thank you whoa
i thought that was weird because it said
shout out against my company i was like
i thought you wanted to shout out shout
out your company likes positive oh no
he's mad he wants to call them out yeah
trent lamalino says what what has to
happen to get luke on jre wanna break
the internet that'd be great
we were like talking about doing
something and it just never happened uh
maybe that'd be cool joe called me up
one day and he's like yo what's up this
loot guy and i was like he sucks
and then we were like
he's like later dude bye and then
probably great friends probably
no no no no
clef the misfit says sitting down to
watch tim cast with my bottle of pepto
bismol that i've had since luke left us
initially but i'm excited to see the
lord's t-shirt vendor has has been
resurrected no puking for me today yes
we have a lot of new t-shirts but i had
to leave uh new hampshire the free state
project beautiful place to go to i was
on a farm i was learning farming how to
work on trucks or i was doing survival
apocalypse drills and trainings uh
working with you know firearms and
working with other important uh
self-defense tools that were uh pretty
handy for the upcoming apocalypse
somebody already made a let's go brandon
t-shirt i bet huh i bet so let's go
brandon huh yeah capitalism yeah yeah
capitalism free market bomb globe says
let's go brandon let's go brandon
that basically means f joe biden now yep
the politically correct brandon that's
how you have to say it if you don't want
to get shut down that's right
km says is she one head going to redeem
herself and join you guys and battle
alex jones she should battle jeff
berwick welcome back luke jimmy dore
needs to make an appearance you are on
his show jimmy is awesome i'm a big fan
we disagree politically on some things
but i think as long as you agree with
like anti-authoritarianism
then we can talk about any other
political policy and economic or social
or whatever well even if you're a jack
boot looking like the italian let's have
you on the show let's discuss your ideas
let's see if your ideas are better than
our ideas and let's let's go at it i
mean we need more honest real
conversations uh and let's get a
perspective let's understand these
people
a lot of people uh you know i would i
would say if we should probably
calculate how much money we make of yuri
besmonov because we get like a handful
of super chats every night of people
being like have you ever watched the
interview with yuri besmanov and i'm
like maybe we should just keep a chart
where it's like we've made like fifty
thousand dollars already and people
asking us to watch it or we should do an
introduction with a graphic of it for a
few seconds in the beginning of the
broadcast we'll just make like a a
whenever someone's super chats yuri
basmanov pops up and says we've seen it
we could do that we agree with you yeah
yuri was kgb right yes and they were
studying the way to disrupt a country's
culture specifically the united states
this is like the intention of what's
happening edward griffin who wrote the
creature from jekyll island was the one
interviewing him in that video so i
interviewed g edward griffin just on
that specific interview and its larger
implications i have some feelers out to
bring edward on the show yeah edward
griffin i'll contact him and and he's an
awesome we'll talk about yuri because
enough yeah finally do a big discussion
about demoralization yeah i mean i did
an interview with him about that it was
fascinating oh yeah on your youtube
channel yeah yeah possibly great we we
with you here as well yeah it'll be
fantastic conversation let's let's do
that treasonous truth says tim you need
you need to listen to iron maiden songs
like holy smoke el dorado and writing on
the wall
i think i know writing on the wall it's
been a while though i'll check them out
iron maiden
sketch m says visited my leftist family
this weekend for my birthday we usually
butt heads and we were all agreeing on
how bad the president is and jab mandate
is crazy
yeah man it's funny when like my biden
loving anti-trump friends were like dude
i'm really worried about this vex
mandate and i'm like
sorry bro like move you asked for it
yeah i mean yeah move
so i got a lot of people who are trying
to get out of the chicago area they're
like i got to get out of here it's
really bad i hear it's not as bad i
don't know i've heard some people say oh
no like you're saying new york isn't as
bad as people think some people are
saying new york's really bad i've heard
from from some people like i can't stand
being in illinois just like it's creepy
and then some people say ah it's fine
but it's really personal preference i
guess if people think something's bad or
not one door closes one door opens
there's a lot of labor shortages out
there you get fired there's a lot of
jobs in florida there's a lot of jobs in
new hampshire there's a lot of jobs in
west virginia you can you can get an
acre of land for a thousand bucks in
west virginia there you go that's right
take out a big loan and live on a land
start your own business oh they got 100
acres for 100k i mean even new hampshire
has lands like this yeah like 100 acres
for like 100 or 200k 2000 an acre is
cheap a lot of people are like that's so
expensive it's like dude people don't
buy houses in cash they go to a bank and
get a loan and get a mortgage okay you
need credit and stuff for that that's
not the thing it's super easy but it's
just it's always mind-blowing to me that
people are like i have no choice i'm
forced to live in new york and i'm like
you could literally walk
into the woods
you're like what you're really saying is
i don't think i would survive on my own
okay well i understand that but you know
there's there's there there is choice
you can be in the system or leave the
system and everything's so much more
expensive in new york city compared to
everywhere else true
thraxis
daedalus says i wanted to give you my
two cents
and say i agree with you on the baseball
debate evil people are trying to change
our attitudes and the game itself will
no longer be recognizable don't sell
your freedom over lentil soup
baxter says the left's stance on israel
is remnant of the cold war when the left
in the u.s sided with fellow leftists
around the world soviet union cuba et
cetera what west did was bad and left
did good see vietnam iran et cetera
israel exists because you uh us uk
nusesar helped opposition
[Music]
freighter says i i came in late so i
increased video speed to catch up live
luke at 1.25 times is gold worth every
penny of the super chat welcome back
luke howdy everyone else i would love to
see that clip it and if you can send it
to my twitter twitter luke we are
hyperspeed luke i'd love to see that
arseon says 14 minutes into the show
luke who came back from buying a pack of
cigarettes is complimenting it
i'm sitting here thinking uh thinking
has tim pool finally converted luke to
being okay with the government
no
crazy
what makes you think that
you're okay with a little bit though
right uh it depends on the context i
mean
i can't make up my mind on on an issue
before hearing up both sides of the
story borders so
again complicated issue if we have a
welfare state i mean obviously this is
going to destroy the state it doesn't
make any sense but obviously we also
have personal liberty and government
shouldn't control people so there's a
big debate here to have depending on
what circumstances we're in so minarcism
i don't i don't even know just just like
less government bullcrap less lies less
less less big corporate monopolies more
chickens everything and more personal
responsibility more decentralization
less centralization so that's it
all right
ayas keen says thanks for your milktoast
content it's a great stepping stone to
full-on lukertarianism just released two
music videos about the government
overlords and pregnant aliens
girls buy a dog make your own music no
dudes ban me make yourself part of the
club you don't want to say that last
part but okay
storm viking says tim's clothes and
beanie are so dark and different looks
like he would wear that to a funeral tim
we don't like change but luke is back so
we forgive you for the change but keep
up the good work you got to get shirts
that are like just one shade off and
then wear them every day and they won't
know
i've
your
channels
every day it's like just something's
different yes oh yeah new studio is
going to be soon i mean they may even be
building it right now
as well as we speak
earlier yeah maybe maybe it's right
under us so it is like the best computer
you can get uh like having all these
cameras we can have eight cameras in the
new studio but we're not gonna we're
gonna use one it's called a ptz camera a
pil uh was it pilt uh pan tilt zoom
tilt what pan tilt zoom and uh is one
camera that can do multiple shots and it
looks amazing
so we're going to have each individual
camera but then we're going to have a
wide shot
the ufo is coming back yeah we have a
new ufo this one is dark the dark ufo so
ian wants to spin it to control the dark
energy i'm doing reiki again
[Laughter]
jay rich says playing devil's advocate
is the world simply getting exactly what
it deserves right now are we in an
overly decadent society where our
biggest worry is what is happening on
social media are we just over fed
animals with manufactured mental issues
yes
those are arguments to make there yes
yep we are very lucky and we are very
spoiled especially compared to the rest
of the world if you're living in america
we don't see it nope
don belmore says tim won't read this
which already proves the entire tweet is
false entire super chat is wrong
99.9 of all doctors are only ever taught
the vaccine schedule and nothing else
they don't know more than an educated
individual
and so the point is
when we had like
you know i won't name any individual
guests but we've had many conservative
guests who have talked about how they
went to their trump supporting doctors
who read all the same articles they did
and had a conversation about the vaccine
and the studies
and some of them say the doctor said i
think for your age group you probably
should get it and some of them you know
told them oh for this medical reason i
don't think so
don't go to a doctor you don't trust and
if you think it's 99.9 then you gotta
ask
a lot of doctors
alexander john says this show is part of
the experiment don't believe me try to
do a single show where you only talk
about positive stories and news see the
algorithm bury you that's more to the
criticism of human nature yeah
like people don't don't necessarily need
so urgency is always a big component of
a sale
if we said like here's good news you
know uh pizza prices went down people
are going to be like well i don't need
to know that right now i'll look that up
later so there's tons of urgency and big
stories like hey something happened
facebook's actually no this is a
positive stream the title of this is all
facebook's apps got nuked following a
hack that's nothing but good news great
this great news everyone's clapping and
cheering what do you mean
and then greg got felt we got some good
news it's not all good news
anthony zavarro says hey tim i am a
registered nurse that used to work for
northwell i saw the writing on the wall
and fled to dallas many of my good
friends were fired they have kids and
mortgages michael dowling the ceo is
cuomo's godfather shaking my ethan head
nothing like andrew cuomo and harvey
weinstein being the perfect
representation of democratic policies
that they're trying to push on everyone
right now so there's a lot of people
that really don't like when i say like
if you oppose the vaccine mandates but
then actually just adhere to them you're
not opposing the vaccine mandates you're
like literally propping them up
so uh you know and i'll say this with
with you know all due respect to all the
good and important things that joe rogan
has has fought for and the social media
economy puts out when he says he opposes
them but then he is literally the
instrument by which the city is able to
enforce them by performing at madison
square garden i'm kind of like yo dude
like the vaccinated exists because
your performance not just you
individually but you know performing
a lot of people get really mad and they
say i don't have a choice i have kids or
whatever and my my response to all of
these people who are like tim doesn't
understand we can't just quit our jobs
and give up everything i'm like dude if
you think you're complying your way out
of this crisis
then i got nothing else to say to you as
luke put it earlier like can't comply
your way out of tyranny and seeing you
make those arguments was one of the
reasons i saw the show i was trolling in
the comments uh sporadically but i saw
that argument and i'm like i need to be
here i need to back you up on this
because this is important for people to
realize i mean this is a moment of
compliance that will literally lead down
a slippery slope that's extremely
dangerous right now and we are literally
tipping at this very moment
it's really simple they said
don't worry the masks are just until the
vaccine comes out and the vaccine came
out and they said put your mask back on
and then they started saying
don't worry the negative tests are just
if you're not vaccinated now some
university have already said you got to
get tested anyway
so when i say
you complying with this is going to be
doomed for your children
and you're like i have no choice my kids
need food i'm like you need to
understand your kids will not have food
the shortages are getting worse today's
show put out a story today saying the
grocery shortages are going to get worse
here's what to expect and you complying
except the way isn't changing that it's
making it happen faster but by all means
life is difficult and i would never i i
can't expect people to to take risks
that i want to take so you don't have to
like me saying it you disagree with me
saying it say i'm wrong by all means
you're allowed to
but i don't i don't i don't know has
there ever been a civilization that
complied its way out of tyranny like
every everyone thinks no no no you look
at the 20th century we and you look up
democide and you really have a rude
awakening to the true reality of
government and history i saw rogan he
performed at madison square garden two
days ago on the second of october and i
saw he posted a video on instagram and
it was like life is a dream for him it's
like the most surreal just eruption of
exuberance from the crowd going wild and
then i started thinking about those nazi
rallies when like hitler would speak and
the people would go wild with exuberance
and like yeah it's exciting and it feels
good
doesn't mean that it's the right thing
well he also posted this video where
it's him talking about like the rise of
tyranny and all this stuff it's
important that he does that
but i'll tell you this man you know i
say this because
i described it as like having someone
grip your heart and squeeze on it when
you're like look i get joe rugged as a
comedian but he's influential he he
speaks to regular working-class people
he speaks to bernie sanders he speaks to
conservatives and so when he can come
out and be like i'm a regular guy a
funny guy
many people of all political factions
like to hear what i have to say and i
tell you these vaccine mandates are
wrong
but i'm going to go be an instrument to
them i'm just like wow dude
that was like brutal it's a big letdown
i saw a lot of comments of a lot of
people being like i really want to see
your show but i can't
i really want to be a part of this but i
can't and just incentivizing it i mean
it needs to be called out we need to
have a conversation about it and it's
you know joe's a good dude he's very
like in the culture war he's one of the
most influential people and he's pushing
back on a lot of the wellness and it's
really really important but like man if
you can't even get joe rogan to be like
i will not support the like he he
shouted out jim brewer which i think is
is a lot because jim brewer is saying i
will not perform at vaccine mandate
places so yeah and the difference is
hitler was
was like speaking horrible dangerous
stuff to those people and joe wasn't
doing that he's like in he's the trojan
horse in a lot of ways and there's
there's one big benefit that by doing
the show a lot of those people that are
adhering to the mandates are going to
hear what he has to say so it's good
but it's tough you know it's it's a
difficult situation you could argue that
look man joe brings those ideas with him
and he's able to go into that arena and
say these things but i'll tell you the
biggest problem i had was
according to the media it is presumed
especially based off of his medical
treatment joe's not vaccinated and i'm
just like is this another hunger games
thing of like the ultra rich are allowed
to go to new york without getting
vaccinated while the plaques are forced
to do it
i
that's a brutal man
all right let's read some more ask dummy
says luke i agree it's being done by
design but our increasing internet
addiction is accelerating collectivism
or the projection of
i.e text just thought not speech how do
we make oversharing on social media
uncool i believe text equals thought not
speech
uh very good point i don't have all the
answers i don't have all the solutions i
think it begins with you trying to be as
healthy and as happy as you can and a
lot of times that means getting away
from big social media and not having it
control your life and i think if you're
really in a in a process to make
yourself better that's going to be one
important realization is to put the
phone down and to interact with people
in real life and to have real
relationships with them and that would
naturally happen on its own but striving
to be better striving to be happy
healthy confident uh and the best
version of yourself is is resistance in
our modern day and age of tyranny that's
uh shoved down our throats in a brave
new world i've heard jordan peterson say
treat yourself like you're someone that
you try that you're trying to help
with helping
advice rook says been a member for a
long time in the hospital with my
stepdaughter getting her gallbladder out
wish caitlyn well for me please caitlyn
we wish you well everyone here at the uh
on the show is hoping for your calendar
you got this
the karen of cod says tim i like to call
people who vote for democrats bird box
voters because they put their blinders
on as soon as their guy gets in office
that's a good one
all right let's see
new name please says i live in las vegas
and my mom is a teacher a school today
had more teachers out than in it seems
every day she mentions another teacher
who retired early the only the old
classical liberals are leaving oh great
and then the institutions are being
taken over by the cult same thing with
the cops a lot a lot of the cops in new
york city are retiring early or
going on leave or just changing jobs
because they yeah yeah my friend yeah my
friend angel who's a
um
a lesbian and also a cop and she's uh
moving to florida geez dude yep what the
heck tough for 15 years i think she's
been a cop yeah
that's not good billy deerhead says like
a mom and dad getting mad at each other
arguing over which child to save i
consider the debate between safety
versus freedom rather foolish the real
villains are the thugs who force that
horrible choice upon them we should be
able to have both
um that's you can't and i'll give you
i'll give you a simple example
you want to go to a war zone for
whatever reason to report
to help or whatever
so you have a choice of the armor you
want to wear maybe you choose 3a you
know it's not going to stop a rifle but
handguns smaller calibers maybe or
definitely
and it's really easy to move around and
it's not very heavy okay well then you
say well that's not good enough i need
more security than that because they got
ak-47s right i need something to
withstand a you know a more powerful
caliber and then okay
well we're going to give you ceramic
plates these are much heavier and they
can withstand like one round from a
rifle and only in like center mass which
is is good now it's heavier and harder
to move
maybe you want you know dragon scale you
know individual ceramic plates layer on
top of each other really really good can
withstand it it's still bulkier and
heavier not as heavy as just straight up
plate it's an improvement
okay well you say look what about my
arms and my legs like i'm going to be
exposed they'll just if there's that
many people okay well we can put you in
an apc
every step of the way as we increase
security you are being restricted in
your movement
in some way you're heavier it's harder
to run that's the reality of security
so
we have a chicken coop
i put a padlock on it i wanted security
because people kept opening it and
leaving it open we have predators so i
got mad and i put a padlock on it now
whenever i go there i have to unlock the
padlock which re restricts my speed and
my ability to move it is a restriction
on everybody including myself but i know
the password
when you increase security typically you
restrict yourself in some way that's a
great when you say the verb secure means
to hold something in place
that's the definition of that word which
is the antithesis of freedom where it's
not held in place
all right i'm going to read this one but
i also want to stress there are many
people in this super chat saying ian is
right in the polling question i don't
want i don't want to read one that was
negative but there's one specific one
rick howell says ian please take a
statistics class sample sizes over about
1500 samples are generally considered
pretty good representations of a
population if the same is uh if the same
is truly random well i won't deny that
it's considered effective i'm just
denying that it is effective
but that's a whole other conversation
loken said this blunt is being smoked in
ian's name that's what i'm talking about
welcome home baby
[Laughter]
bozeman junk removal and hauling says
tim and luke would would you suggest and
promote your parents divorce and let
your five siblings just get whatever
step parent and new life they get that
yes well if your parents are beating the
crap out of you robbing stealing you of
any real existence i think sometimes you
know again i'm a family person i believe
in family families are under attack but
if it's destructive and hurting you you
got to make a decision that's right for
you but let's let's let's get in there a
little bit more
so in west virginia i can walk into any
building without an id or a passport i
can buy what i want there's there's no
mask mandates so if i have one parent
who's supportive respectful of my
choices and says i want to see you
flourish and lower taxes and no taxes on
weapons and ammo and constitutional
carry saying you know look son i believe
in your i believe in you you're smart
i'm gonna let you do what you want
within reason we still have laws i'm
still here your parent and then you have
another parent who is like beating you
and screaming in your face and telling
you how dumb you are
i'd be like y'all need to get a divorce
and i'm moving with him
yeah or her whichever parent was a good
parent yeah if someone's hurting you i
mean most people are in an abusive
relationship and it's the relationship
that they have with government and and
maybe there are people on the left who
are like well what if you've got a
neglectful parent who doesn't care that
you're like playing with matches and
we're here with the responsible parents
saying you need to stop running with
scissors and i'll be like then you can
advocate for the parents to split up and
go live with with whatever parent is
the overprotecting one or the protective
one that you like and you know i'll go
do my thing there we're all happy right
i gotta say as bad as it would be
internationally
peaceful divorce i think would make
everybody happy
look you live in new york lower taxes
no more no more federal governments
telling you your state can't do what it
wants to do california you want all the
immigrants to come no more federal
government trying to stop you from doing
it you want to you want to do drugs no
more federal government stopping you
from doing it you live in west virginia
hey no more taxes no more atf my
every time we have this conversation has
come back to the utopia of peaceful
divorce i just see it that it would
never be peaceful
well it's what you think it is because
you know there's ways of approaching it
and dealing with it and and the state
also is really busy and overrun as well
and also incompetent in many areas so
there's a lot of different possibilities
there's a lot of different scenarios but
the one you kind of think of the one
that you think is real is most likely
the one and that's why i always believe
in trying to be as optimistic i do
believe there's a possible situation
where people could peacefully move away
from each other respect each other's
differences even with like states like
new hampshire if they do succeed they
don't get any federal money they don't
give any federal money i think you know
when things start decaying especially
economically
those moves will be made even without
being officially announced but
they will happen in a way where uh it
will be unofficially that way yeah if it
has to happen because of economic
disparity i could see it happening
exactly because it has to happen
so so there's multiple different
realities there's multiple different
possibilities striving for the best one
is something we should always do and
think as positively as we could about
what future we could build uh
comparatively to thinking of negative
ones
all right let's uh we'll just read maybe
uh one more here
genesis annesbro says the other day i
saw a car with a decent-sized hunger
games mockingjay sticker and right
underneath it they had a biden sticker i
had to share
that's where we're at my friends longer
games the wealthy elites don't have
rules they can fly in private planes
they can in new york city's vaccine
mandate literally says performers are
exempt from the vaccine mandate
so does it really yep i did not know
that performers are exempt so you can
put on a show
and you can you don't got to get
vaccinated only the people who come to
see it it's like the met gala it's just
the elites of song oh yeah and you can
point your camera into the audience and
make them all part of the performance
and then no one has to get vaccinated i
don't i don't i don't think they would
just how far does it stretch yeah you
know they'd be like you're not
performing but you know you can
certainly try you can make the audience
part of it that being said my friends
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
always it really does help and go to
timcast.com because that members only
segment will be coming up around 11 or
so p.m and we'll talk about all the
spicy good stuff
plus we have like a whole bunch of other
really awesome
all these other really awesome videos we
got you know alex jones allen west we
got steve bannon bonus segments so
definitely you want to be a member there
and support our fierce independent
independent journalism you can follow me
at timcast basically everywhere assuming
they're still up and you can follow at
tim cast irl which is the show uh aaron
you want to shout anything out
go follow me on youtube arielle
scarcella please
i need more sane people on my channel
yes
i am of course the humble t-shirt vendor
and the shirt that i'm wearing right now
says i tested positive for refusing to
live in fear and if you want it you can
get it exclusively on
thebestpoliticoshirts.com
i also have 10 years of video of raw
unfiltered content of everything that i
can't say here all on luke
uncensored.com i hope to see you there
i'm happy you guys are back stay neutral
i'm ian crosslin
thank you guys for tuning in people
laugh at me but i really like mondays
because i get to hang out with all the
people at work and all our cool guests
you guys may follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlist i'm about to cross 100 000
followers so i would love to see you
there
we will see all of you over at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out bye
guys
you